programming throwdown episode 174 devops take it away jason hey Hey, everybody. So this episode, we're going to cover DevOps. For people who are new to the show, we're going to cover it somewhere in the middle. We'll talk about news and some other things first. That is the number one comment we get is, why did you take so long to talk about DevOps? You're going to learn a whole bunch of cool stuff today. If you're a brand new listener, welcome to the show. So I wanted to kick it off with a project that I built, which I'm pretty proud of. It's one of these things, you probably have this feeling, whether you're doing woodworking or stuff in the backyard or robotics or anything, you have a project and you say to yourself,
Programming Throwdown 第 174 期，DevOps，Jason 你来主持。嘿，大家好。这一期我们要聊聊 DevOps。对于新听众，我们会在节目中间部分讨论这个话题。我们会先聊聊新闻和其他一些事情。我们收到的头号评论就是：为什么你们花了这么久才聊 DevOps？今天你们会学到很多很酷的东西。如果你是新听众，欢迎来到本节目。我想先从我做的一个项目开始，我对此感到非常自豪。这就像是那种感觉，无论你是在做木工、在后院干活、搞机器人还是做任何事，当你有一个项目时，你会对自己说：
this is a coin toss, whether this is going to work or not and it's kind of exciting it's it's like um you know it's kind of like a rush because that that sort of randomness right um and then you know as it really is a coin toss half of them you know don't work and just decay into dust half the projects work really well this is what i feel like works pretty well um i created a linkedin uh social media bot um but it doesn't do what you think you know most of these bots go out and like harass people or maybe that's not the right word solicit people right mine is the opposite so mine is a defender it defends me against the other bots and so the way this works is it uses a large language model. So I'm using ChatGPT.
这就像抛硬币，不知道能不能成，但这种感觉很刺激，就像……你知道，这是一种冲动，因为那种随机性，对吧？然后你知道，这确实就像抛硬币，一半的项目可能行不通，最后化为尘埃，而另一半则运行得非常好。我觉得这个项目运行得相当不错。我创建了一个 LinkedIn 社交媒体机器人，但它不是你想的那种。你知道，大多数这种机器人会出去骚扰别人，或者说“拉拢”别人，对吧？我的正好相反，它是一个防御者，保护我不受其他机器人的骚扰。它的工作原理是使用大语言模型，我用的是 ChatGPT。
It has like in the cookies file, uses a headless browser with the right cookies set up. So it's logged into my LinkedIn account, goes on LinkedIn, accepts any connection requests, and then goes to my messages, looks at the unread messages, and I ask ChatGPT, is this a solicitation? Is this someone trying to sell me engineering services? And I tell ChatGPT, answer yes or no, followed by an explanation. And the next one is, is this somebody who is looking to work at my place of work? Um, and based on these answers, it sends automatic responses. And so I actually, in the. And I paste the chat sheet answer. And then I mute the thread and put it in the other category.
它在 cookie 文件里，使用一个无头浏览器并设置了正确的 cookie。所以它登录了我的 LinkedIn 账号，进入 LinkedIn，接受任何好友请求，然后去我的消息列表，查看未读消息，我问 ChatGPT：“这是推销吗？这是有人想向我推销工程服务吗？”我告诉 ChatGPT：“回答是或否，并给出解释。”下一个问题是：“这是想来我公司工作的人吗？”根据这些回答，它会自动发送回复。然后我把 ChatGPT 的回答粘贴进去，静音该对话，并将其归入“其他”类别。
And this has worked amazing. So first off, after some testing, I kicked it off. I got banned three times from LinkedIn because not banned, yeah, not banned, but like throttled, you know, or like literally if, if from my desktop, I went to linkedin.com, I just got like a HTTP timeout or something. So like they throttled me, uh, completely, but, um, but eventually it went through my entire backlog of unread messages. And the other thing it does is if it doesn't catch this as a solicitation, it marks it as safe. And so I have a safe list.
这效果好极了。首先，经过一些测试后，我启动了它。我被 LinkedIn 封了三次，不是封号，对，不是封号，而是被限流了。你知道，或者说从我的桌面端访问 linkedin.com 时，我直接收到了 HTTP 超时之类的错误。所以他们完全限制了我的访问，但最终它处理完了我所有的未读消息积压。另一件事是，如果它没有将其识别为推销，它会将其标记为安全。所以我有一个白名单。
And so when I was done, I looked at it because I had thousands of unread messages. And it was almost all spam, right? But then when I was done, I looked and there was all these people who were legitimate people who had interesting things to say who I now could see. It's like basically like I had a handful of needles, you know, like the haystack was burnt to the crisp and what I was left with is all the needles. And so some of the people I reached out to were surprised. One person was upset that it took me eight years to respond. But a lot of people is, is like,
当我做完后，我查看了一下，因为我有几千条未读消息。几乎全是垃圾信息，对吧？但当我做完后，我发现里面有很多合法的、有话要说的人，我终于能看到他们了。这基本上就像我手里有一把针，你知道，干草堆被烧成了灰烬，剩下的就是所有的针。所以，我联系的一些人感到很惊讶。有一个人很不高兴，因为我花了八年时间才回复。但很多人是……
I built a lot of connections with people who just, you know, serendipitously like, or just, you know, message me on LinkedIn and I just couldn't see it. So, so it was an amazing experience.
我与那些只是……你知道，偶然联系我，或者在 LinkedIn 上给我发消息，而我却没看到的人建立了许多联系。所以，这是一次很棒的经历。
And so now what I did is created a cron job that runs on my Raspberry Pi, which runs the same process every hour. And for example, at 4 a.m. and at 9 a.m. today, it sent automatic messages and muted to people who are trying to sell me software services. So that's just today, this morning. So it's pretty awesome it's kind of weird but uh it's pretty cool i think the the idea is interesting i mean i guess the incentives in the system are a bit weird because linkedin doesn't really have an incentive
现在我做了一个 cron 任务，在我的树莓派上运行，每小时执行相同的流程。例如，今天凌晨 4 点和上午 9 点，它自动给那些试图向我推销软件服务的人发送了消息并静音了他们。所以这只是今天早上的情况。这太棒了，虽然有点奇怪，但我认为这个想法很有趣。我的意思是，系统中的激励机制有点奇怪，因为 LinkedIn 并没有动力
to stop the spam as long as if like it doesn't overwhelm and like mess up user retention so like some some people may like it's it's also a personal thing like some of the stuff you might consider spam other people might consider like if you're searching for a job some of those people reaching out may be like oh i want to reply to them like i'm i'm right right and so yeah i i mean the getting throttled it makes sense it's very hard to distinguish between someone doing like what you're doing and someone you know scraping a bunch of hacked linkedin accounts that you know trying to get everyone's personal data but yeah i mean i was definitely nervous when i got throttled that like i had
去阻止垃圾信息，只要它没有让用户不堪重负并影响留存率。所以有些人可能……这也是个人的事，有些你认为是垃圾信息的东西，别人可能认为是……如果你正在找工作，那些联系你的人可能就是“哦，我想回复他们，我就是这样”，所以，被限流是有道理的，很难区分像你这样的人和那些试图抓取被黑的 LinkedIn 账号以获取个人数据的人。但说实话，当我被限流时，我确实很紧张，担心我
inadvertently got myself kicked off linkedin but but uh um yeah so i just to double down on that for friends i have friends at LinkedIn and you guys totally did the right thing by throttling me. I don't feel like that was the wrong... I'm glad that it didn't last forever. But oh yeah, you hit on something really important, which is there's this spam like, hey, I'm in Nigeria. I have a billion dollars. I just need you to send me your credit card. And then there's what you said, which is like, I think solicitations is the better word. And in fact, like even this chat GBT thing, the very first thing I ask is, is this a person looking to offer me a job? And if it is, then i mark them as safe so like clearly like there's
无意中让自己被踢出了 LinkedIn。但为了重申这一点，我有朋友在 LinkedIn 工作，你们完全做对了，限流我是对的。我不觉得那是错的……我很高兴它没有持续太久。但你说到了一个非常重要的问题，那就是有一种垃圾信息是：“嘿，我在尼日利亚，我有十亿美元，我只需要你把信用卡号发给我。”然后就是你说的，我觉得“推销”这个词更准确。事实上，即使是这个 ChatGPT 的东西，我问的第一个问题是：“这是想给我提供工作的人吗？”如果是，我就把他们标记为安全，所以很明显
some solicitations i'm interested in and then others i'm not and and i don't expect like linkedin to mark those as spam right or have that nuance yeah so i guess like that's one of those i you know i guess you call it fine tuning or whatever like at the limit being able to describe your preferences in a maybe just a you know chain of consciousness style like way you're thinking about it and having it tuned to those preferences like i am interested in jobs that are legitimate but i'm not interested in job offers that are clearly just blasts and have none of my personal information in them like the person didn't bother to do research and you can kind of list off all the things you're interested in and
有些推销是我感兴趣的，而另一些则不是，我不指望 LinkedIn 把那些标记为垃圾信息，或者有那种细微差别。所以我想这就是……我猜你称之为微调或者其他什么，在极限情况下，能够以一种意识流的方式描述你的偏好，并根据这些偏好进行调整。比如，我对合法的职位感兴趣，但我对那些显然只是群发、没有任何我个人信息的职位邀请不感兴趣，因为对方甚至懒得做研究。你可以列出所有你感兴趣的事情，然后
kind of build the yeah like you said like it's a you can do a lot of probably what you're doing with natural language filters or just like going in and doing basic stuff it just you wouldn't take the time it's not worth it right right like for me to build some nlp thing it would take me a long time versus this only took me maybe three four hours um and you know the the false uh alarm rate is not the best uh you know i actually um somebody texted me uh and i i had muted them on linkedin and they actually knew me from a meetup that i run here in austin and and uh they sent me a text so yeah there's definitely the false alarm rate is let's's say 5% or something, which is not great. But for an application like this,
就像你说的，你可以用自然语言过滤器或者做一些基础的事情来完成你所做的大部分工作，只是你不会花时间去做，不值得，对吧？对我来说，构建某种 NLP 模型需要很长时间，而这个只花了我三四个小时。而且，误报率不是最好的，你知道，实际上有人给我发短信，而我在 LinkedIn 上静音了他们，他们其实认识我，因为我在这里（奥斯汀）举办过聚会，他们给我发了短信。所以，误报率大概是 5% 左右，这不算太好。但对于这样的应用，
I think it's fine. I'm not landing a space shuttle or anything like this. But it definitely, when you go and look at all the people messaging you and you auto messaging them and muting them, like every now and then I'll go and look at it. It makes me think of what a weird world we live in where someone has, you know,
我觉得没问题。我不是在降落航天飞机。但当你去查看所有给你发消息的人，而你自动回复并静音他们时，偶尔我会去看看。这让我想到我们生活在一个多么奇怪的世界，有人有一个
a machine that messages me and my machine answers it. And, and it's all like natural language. Like, it looks like they messaged me, you know, manually. And it looks like I responded to them manually,
给我发消息的机器，而我的机器回答了它。而且，这一切都是自然语言。看起来就像他们手动给我发了消息，看起来就像我手动回复了他们，
but it's all, it's all just fake. I think, I think that was on, Oh, I think it was Lex Friedman talking to Yann LeCun and, and, uh,
但这一切都是假的。我想，我想那是在……哦，我想是 Lex Friedman 和 Yann LeCun 的对话，
uh, LeCun was saying the same, something similar, which is we always think that, Oh, there's going to be some propaganda, uh, campaign that,
LeCun 说着类似的话，即我们总是认为会有某种宣传活动，
you know, somebody is going to use chat GPT to just be super convincing with fake news. He's like, what people miss is that if they can do that, you can too. And so a lot of our email and correspondence at some point in the future, likely it was astonishing that we effectively ran open ports, uh, and like, let everyone just send everything they want to us. Um, and instead we'll have secretaries that are trained on our behalf to like filter out that stuff you know and you'll just have your bots talking to their bots and some stuff we'll get through but most of it you know will be be sort of caught by intelligent filters on our side and so yeah they'll develop together yeah i mean scott galloway from the nyu business school had this
有人会利用 ChatGPT 来制造非常令人信服的假新闻。他说，人们忽略的是，如果他们能做到，你也能。所以我们未来的很多电子邮件和通信，在某种程度上，我们现在有效地运行开放端口，让每个人都能随心所欲地给我们发送任何东西，这真是令人震惊。相反，未来我们将会有代表我们训练的秘书来过滤掉那些东西，你会有你的机器人和他们的机器人对话，有些东西会通过，但大部分会被我们这边的智能过滤器捕获。所以，它们会共同发展。是的，纽约大学商学院的 Scott Galloway 有个
talk that i watched where he was talking about, um, Amazon having this unfair advantage, because if you search for just the word batteries on amazon.com, you got their batteries first and how that's, uh, you know, just a huge advantage for them. I don't think he was going down the, you know,
演讲，我看了，他在谈论亚马逊拥有这种不公平的优势，因为如果你在 amazon.com 上搜索“电池”这个词，你会先看到他们的电池，这对他来说是一个巨大的优势。我不认为他是在走“这不公平”的路线。我想他更多是在说这对他们来说是一个巨大的优势。所以你可以想象未来，当你在亚马逊上搜索某样东西时，会有某种浏览器插件根据你的兴趣重新排序。所以现在你的排序与服务器的排序在竞争。是的，这是一场军备竞赛。我的意思是，以一种我想要某种东西来代表我筛选信息的方式与社交媒体互动，听起来很有吸引力，
it's not fair route. I think he was more just saying what a tremendous advantage it is for them. And so you can imagine a future where when you search for something on Amazon, there's some browser plugin that re-ranks it that has your interests. And so now your ranking kind of fights with the server's ranking. Yeah, it's an arms race. I mean, it sort of sounds appealing to engage with social media in a way where it's like, I want something to go through and curate stuff on my behalf
它为我工作，并由我激励，而不是社交媒体公司试图获得参与度，或者向我推送绝对的垃圾，或者试图让我停留更长时间以找到金子，对吧？他们是有激励的。即使他们 100% 知道我感兴趣的东西，他们也有动力以特定的重复频率分散展示它们，
that works for me and incentivized by me rather than the social media companies trying to get engagement or push just absolute crap to me or try to get me to stay on longer to find the nuggets, right? Like they're incentivized. Even if they 100% know the things I'm interested in, they're incentivized to spread them out at like a specific repetition
这样我就会花更多时间，看更多广告，所以他们不断向我展示其他可能只是刚好符合我兴趣的东西，让我不至于点击离开。所以有人去筛选掉所有这些，当然会破坏所有的广告模式，但这听起来确实是一种有趣的消费媒体的方式。是的，完全同意。所以，各位，如果你想在 LinkedIn 上与我联系，我会接受所有人，然后你可以说……好吧，我不会亲自接受，但我的 AI 会接受。说服 Jason 的 AI 机器人，他会分享给你。是的，如果你在 LinkedIn 上给我发消息，推销你在东欧的软件开发公司，以及他们如何能比我更便宜地做软件，
interval so that i spend more time see more ads and so they keep showing me other stuff that's maybe just close enough that i don't click away or whatever and so to have somebody go through and filter all that out it ruins all the advertising models of course but uh it does sound an interesting way to consume media yeah yeah totally um so yeah folks out there uh if you want uh connect with me on linkedin i will accept everybody and then you can say if you well i will literally accept well i won't accept it but my ai will accept it convince jace's ai bot and he'll share with you yeah if you if you message me on linkedin about your software development company in Eastern Europe and how they can do software cheaper than I can
或者类似的事情，你会被屏蔽，这会很有趣。好了，接下来是……哦，关于那个的最后一件事。代码也完全在 GitHub 上公开。只要在 GitHub 上搜索我，Jason Gauchies，找到我最近的仓库，你就可以获取所有代码并自己运行。好了，接下来是新闻。新闻，我的第一条新闻：当我构建这个 LinkedIn 自动回复器时，我使用了 Amazon Q，这是那种 Copilot 类型的工具之一。Patrick，你用过 GitHub Copilot 或 Amazon Q 或类似的工具吗？没有，我没用过。我的意思是，在我的工作中，它
or whatever it is, you will get blocked and it will be pretty funny. All right, on to... Oh, one last thing about that. The code is also totally available on GitHub. Just look me up on GitHub,ub aren't them a jason gauchies find my most recent repository um you can get all the code and run it yourself um all right on to news news uh my first news so when i was building this linkedin autoresponder i used amazon q which is uh you know one of these co-pilot type things patrick have you ever used github co-pilot or amazon q or any of these no i haven't i mean at my work it's it's
是被禁止的。而且正如我在这里多次承认的那样，我并没有像我应该做的那样把编程当作爱好，所以它在我的工作中也被禁止了。所以这是我第一次使用它的机会。你知道，“禁止”这个词可能不太对。更多的是……不，是的，确实如此。它可能还没被考虑过。哦，不。对我们来说，就像是……
sort of a band and i uh as i've admitted many times on here they don't do as much coding as a hobby as i should so it's also banned in my work So this was my first opportunity to use it. You know, banned isn't the right word. It's more just like... No, yeah, exactly. It hasn't been considered, maybe. Oh, no. For us, it's like, yeah, it's...
你不想把你的代码上传到某个地方，对吧？为了获得评论。哦，我不知道这个工具是否会那样做。它是那样做的，还是只是运行？大多数都会。或者至少有条款规定它们可以上传你代码的一部分。你知道，我甚至没想过这一点。我只是假设它是在我的桌面上运行的，但你可能是对的。无论如何，我试了一下，它太棒了。所以我给你举一些例子，
You don't want to upload your code to somewhere, right? In order to get comments on it. Oh, I don't know if this one even does that, though. Does it do that or does it just run? Most of them do. Or at least have clauses that they could upload portions of yours. you know that's something i didn't even think about i just assumed that it was running on my desktop but you're probably right actually um okay at any rate so i tried i tried this out um it was awesome so i'll give you some examples like
我发现非常令人印象深刻的具体例子。这些都很小。这是其中的一部分，你知道，那种“帮我写整个网站”的 ChatGPT。我一直对此持极度怀疑态度，原因有很多。最大的原因是项目是由许多模块组成的，你希望它们具有某种主题一致性。所以，我带着怀疑的态度进去，认为这真的没什么帮助，但它做的一件事是……
really concrete examples of things i found really impressive. So and these are all going to be tiny. So this is part of it is, you know, the whole like build me an entire website chat GPT. I've been extremely skeptical of that for a whole bunch of different reasons. The biggest one is that projects are many modules that you want to have like some thematic consistency. Right. So I kind of went in pretty skeptical thinking this is not really going to help but one thing that it did was you
你知道，我有一个变量叫 finished，然后我写了 while not finished，后来在那个 while 循环里，我放了……我想我放了 finished 等于……如果我没记错的话……哦，不，抱歉，我写了 while true，我有一个变量叫 finished，然后我输入了 if finished，它自动补全了冒号和换行符。再次强调，这不是什么大不了的事，但它确实弄清楚了：好的，变量叫 finished，它在一个 while true 循环里，所以如果它完成了，你只想跳出循环，对吧？还有一件事，
know i had a variable called finished and uh uh you know i had while while not finished and so then later on inside that while loop um i put uh um i put i think i put finished equals if i get this right oh no sorry i had while true and i had a variable called finished and then i typed if finished and then it auto completed you know colon new line break again like not not like a big deal but like it kind of figured out like okay the variable is called finished it's inside a wild true loop so if it's finished you want to just punch out of the loop right um there was another thing where um oh yeah so i was using this library called playwright to do the web automation and um when i went to run a function, it figured out that I should set this parameter, there was like a wait time parameter. And it looked further up and figured out, oh,
哦，是的，我正在使用这个叫 Playwright 的库来进行网页自动化，当我运行一个函数时，它算出我应该设置这个参数，有一个等待时间参数。它往上看了一下，发现哦，
I'd set this wait time parameter before. And so I'm going to want to set it again. And so right when I put the open parentheses, it was like wait time equals two seconds or a constant whatever it was so it was impressive um i actually was really really surprised i i was very skeptical i was expecting to uninstall it right away um there were a couple of times where it wanted to auto generate like 30 lines of garbage like literally just garbage characters so it's not perfect by any means um but it was uh i would say it's a net productivity gain you know i was really surprised and you feed it your like context of your entire project in advance or it's doing this from like common available code that it knows about i have no idea have no idea. I mean, basically, I'll tell you what I did as a user.
我之前设置过这个等待时间参数。所以我肯定想再次设置它。所以当我输入左括号时，它就显示 wait time 等于两秒或者其他常量。所以这令人印象深刻。我真的很惊讶，我非常怀疑，我本来打算马上卸载它的。有几次它想自动生成 30 行垃圾代码，字面意思就是垃圾字符，所以它绝不完美。但我想说，这是一个净生产力提升。你知道，我真的很惊讶。你是提前把整个项目的上下文喂给它，还是它从它知道的通用代码中做到的？我不知道，我真的不知道。我的意思是，基本上，我告诉你我作为用户做了什么。
I installed the extension. It makes you create an AWS builder account, which is separate from any other Amazon or AWS accounts you have. So I had to create a new account. And that was it. Under the hood, it could have uploaded my entire project to the internet. I really have no... I mean, it was an open source project anyways, so I'm not going to lose. But yeah, I really don't know what it was doing under the hood, but it was really clever.
我安装了扩展程序。它让你创建一个 AWS Builder 账号，这与你拥有的任何其他 Amazon 或 AWS 账号是分开的。所以我不得不创建一个新账号。就是这样。在底层，它可能已经把我的整个项目上传到了互联网上。我真的没有……我的意思是，它本来就是一个开源项目，所以我不会有什么损失。但是的，我真的不知道它在底层做了什么，但它真的很聪明。
I look forward to this. I mean, I think this would be one of those things where it used to be, I remember, that was a long time ago, Google used to sell search appliances. Oh, yeah, that's right. And for the same thing, you would put them in your infrastructure internal on your network at a company and it would index all of your internal websites and webpages. So you go to like an internal Google. Now a lot of that has been integrated in other tooling and other solutions. And so we don't really think about that anymore. But I think something similar will happen here where you'll have on premise boxes initially, because it's the only way to really guarantee I guess it's it's sort of safe for AWS instances, maybe. And you'll upload company, you know, your repositories and have this stuff crunch on it. Yeah, yeah, that makes a ton of sense. I know there's a bunch of open source versions of this
我很期待这个。我的意思是，我认为这会是那种曾经……我记得，那是很久以前的事了，Google 曾经销售搜索设备。哦，是的，没错。同样的事情，你会把它们放在公司内部的基础设施网络中，它会索引你所有的内部网站和网页。所以你会去类似内部 Google 的地方。现在很多功能已经集成到其他工具和解决方案中了。所以我们不再考虑这个问题了。但我认为这里也会发生类似的事情，你会先有本地盒子，因为这是唯一能保证……我想这对 AWS 实例来说是安全的，也许吧。你会上传公司的仓库，让这些东西处理它。是的，这非常有道理。我知道有很多开源版本
that you can run locally or run in your own cloud. So I know the technology is there. It's just a matter of time. Very cool. Mine's on a pretty opposite end of the spectrum, I guess. And that is, I've seen a series of these. So I just want to highlight, I picked one to focus on, but there's actually two, which is there's a series of very cheap RIS v or risk five i don't think i don't
你可以本地运行或在自己的云中运行。所以我知道技术已经存在了。这只是时间问题。非常酷。我的新闻处于光谱的另一端，我想。那就是，我看到了一系列这样的东西。所以我只想重点介绍一个，但实际上有两个，那就是有一系列非常便宜的 RISC-V 处理器。我不记得……
remember yeah risk five okay that's what i was gonna say uh the risk five uh processors are starting to kind of roll out and also i saw like commodity prices so i think they're like 10 cents um roughly for one of these processors you have any i don't have any yet it's on my yes i have them in my cart on aliex, but they're kind of expensive there. So I need to find another place to buy them from. And yeah, I found them very expensive as well. I was looking at the Mars something and it was like 200 bucks.
是的，RISC-V，好的，这就是我要说的。RISC-V 处理器开始推出，我也看到了商品价格，我想它们大约是 10 美分一个。你有吗？我还没有，它在我的购物车里，在 AliExpress 上，但它们在那里有点贵。所以我需要找另一个地方买。是的，我也发现它们非常贵。我当时在看 Mars 什么的，要 200 美元。
I was like, I can get a Raspberry Pi 5 for that. So, okay. So maybe these people are out to help us. So a YouTuber by the name of BitLuni, B-I-T-L-U-N-I, if you've never seen him before, lots of interesting computer related projects there. He built a super cluster of 256 of these with some interesting discussions, if it's not something you've ever considered before. But if you want to have 256 processors talking to each other, how do you
我当时想，我可以用那个钱买个树莓派 5。所以，也许这些人不是来帮我们的。所以，一个叫 BitLuni 的 YouTuber，如果你以前没见过他，那里有很多有趣的计算机相关项目。他用 256 个这种处理器构建了一个超级集群，如果这是你从未考虑过的事情，会有一些有趣的讨论。但如果你想让 256 个处理器互相交谈，你如何
handle that as like putting them on a bus? And what is the communications matrix look like? And how do you organize it and think about it? And then, you know, how do you tell if they're all working or not? And he's not the, you know, of course, other people have built, you know, very high core count, even production processors before but at a hobbyist level it's kind of nuts uh you would never have spent whatever it is you know five dollars for a processor and then 256 of them but at 10 cents each and pcb prices have come down to sort of make your own boards and so it's just interesting time to kind of consider consider some of these and the nice thing about these which i think
处理这个问题，比如把它们放在总线上？通信矩阵是什么样的？你如何组织和思考它？然后，你如何判断它们是否都在工作？他不是……当然，其他人以前也构建过非常高核心数的生产级处理器，但在业余爱好者层面，这有点疯狂。你永远不会花五美元买一个处理器，然后买 256 个。但每个 10 美分，而且 PCB 价格已经下降到可以自己制作电路板的程度，所以这是一个考虑这些东西的有趣时间。关于这些芯片的好事，我认为
there's a pair of them that are pretty similar ch32v i think one is 003 and the other is 203 so ch32v203 these are the chips um but often what happens is they these chips are very very cheap and if you get help from the company and you need to put them in like your hair dryer to display you know to control the temperature output or something you could buy one of these but if you get help from the company and you need to put them in like your hair dryer to display you know to control the temperature output or something you could buy one of these but if you want to do hobbyist stuff with it getting an sdk getting documentation is pretty hard so you need a sort of critical mass of people to get you know good english translations and sdk and the very very popular um i guess example of this is if you hear people talking about, oh, hey, what?
有一对非常相似的，CH32V，我想一个是 003，另一个是 203，所以 CH32V203，这些是芯片。但通常发生的情况是，这些芯片非常非常便宜，如果你从公司获得帮助，你需要把它们放进你的吹风机里来显示温度输出或类似的东西，你可以买这些。但如果你想用它做业余爱好者的东西，获取 SDK 和文档非常困难。所以你需要一定数量的人来获得好的英文翻译和 SDK。非常非常流行的例子是，如果你听到人们谈论，哦，嘿，什么？
I just want the S, no, not the STM32. What are the little Wi-Fi chips? You were using them, Jason. Oh, why is my? The Pico, Raspberry Pi Pico. Ah, no, now my brain failed me. Oh, this is a bad time. Oh, the ESP32.
我只想要 S，不，不是 STM32。那些小的 Wi-Fi 芯片是什么？你以前用过它们，Jason。哦，为什么我的……Pico，树莓派 Pico。啊，不，现在我的大脑短路了。哦，这真是个糟糕的时间。哦，ESP32。
Yeah, thank you. Thank you. I was going to say STM32, but ESP32. Those are two different things. The ESP32 is similar. It was like a very cheap commodity thing that was like going in light bulbs and it wasn't useful. And then hobbyists sort of realized, wait, this is actually, you know, we can get good documentation for it. And now there's a huge, you know, community of people developing things for ESP32 and other chips. And I don't know for the company if it made an impact or not. But for hobbyists, it's certainly cool to get access to these really
是的，谢谢。谢谢。我本来想说 STM32，但 ESP32。那是两码事。ESP32 很相似。它就像一个非常便宜的商品，被用在灯泡里，没什么用。然后业余爱好者意识到，等等，这实际上……我们可以为它获得好的文档。现在有一个庞大的社区在为 ESP32 和其他芯片开发东西。我不知道这对公司是否有影响。但对于业余爱好者来说，能够接触到这些来自 Espressif（我相信是那家公司）的非常便宜的东西，确实很酷。所以现在我们开始看到同样的事情，调试工具，这些 RISC-V 处理器的编译器工具链。它们非常便宜，部分原因是它们不需要为 RISC-V 架构本身支付许可费，所以你可以买到更便宜的。并不是每个人总是支付许可费，但肯定的是，现在它们绝对可以。然后，在节目笔记中，我没有很好的方法来做，但如果你搜索“用 RISC-V 芯片驱动辉光管”，你会发现这里有一个链接，指向一个我以前没见过的 YouTuber，
cheap things from this Espressif, I believe is that company. So now we're starting to see the same thing, debug tools, compiler tool chains for these RISC-V processors. And they're ridiculously cheap, in part because they don't have to pay a licensing fee for the risk five architecture itself and so you can get them even cheaper not that everyone always pays licensing fees but for sure now like they they definitely can't and then um in the show notes i don't have a great way to do it but if you search a powering a nixie tube from a risk 5 uh chip you'll find there is a link here to a youtuber who i hadn't run across before um but they built a um like a boost buck boost controller from a microprocessor so actually taking usb sort of five volt power and like going
但他们用微处理器构建了一个升压/降压控制器。实际上是获取 USB 的 5 伏电源，然后升压到……
i think it was 200 volts to power a nixie tube which is a little like vacuum tube except it displays numerals instead of like oh wow a transistor i think it's oh i did a cnl ohr look in the show notes uh or search powering a nixie tube from usb with a 10 cent risk 5 processor and so they i guess we're doing something at a not coordinating with the other person bit loony but they both end up having something they have a bunch of cool stuff on their channel as well. So worth checking out. So adding this definitely to my list of like, things that would be cool to play with. And as Jason has told us on the show before, you know, there is a risk of letting out the magic smoke. So spending, you know, 10 cents on a processor makes letting out the magic smoke much less painful yeah yeah totally um
我想是 200 伏来驱动辉光管，它有点像真空管，除了它显示数字而不是……哦，哇，晶体管，我想是……哦，我做了……看节目笔记，或者搜索“用 10 美分的 RISC-V 处理器通过 USB 驱动辉光管”。所以他们……我想是在做一些事情，没有和 BitLuni 协调，但他们最终都有一些东西。他们的频道上也有很多很酷的东西。所以值得一看。所以肯定要把这个加到我的“玩起来会很酷”的清单里。正如 Jason 之前在节目中告诉我们的，你知道，让“魔法烟雾”跑出来是有风险的。所以花 10 美分买个处理器，让魔法烟雾跑出来时就不会那么心疼了。是的，完全同意。
yeah i feel like just personally at the level where like i have to put the processor somewhere and put the ram in another spot and the wi-fi chip in another spot and hook them all together that's like one level below where i'm interested like like the uh that's why i was looking at the this mars thing. I can't remember the exact one, but it was basically a Raspberry Pi where you have the Wi-Fi, you have the Bluetooth, you have an Ethernet port, HDMI port, all that stuff,
是的，我个人觉得，在那种我必须把处理器放在一个地方，把内存放在另一个地方，把 Wi-Fi 芯片放在另一个地方，然后把它们全部连在一起的层面，那比我感兴趣的层面低一级。这就是为什么我在看那个 Mars 的东西。我不记得确切的型号了，但它基本上是一个树莓派，你有 Wi-Fi，你有蓝牙，你有以太网口，HDMI 接口，所有这些东西，
but it's RISC-V. And for some reason, those are still really expensive, but I think it might be just that they're not mass-producing them yet. Yeah, I think they'll come. I think the dev boards, I mean, I'm seeing dev boards in the sub $5 range for some of these CH32s. I don't know what the proper abbreviation is for these, but they don't have Wi-Fi and
但它是 RISC-V 的。出于某种原因，那些仍然非常昂贵，但我认为可能只是因为它们还没有大规模生产。是的，我想它们会来的。我认为开发板，我的意思是，我看到一些 CH32 的开发板在 5 美元以下。我不知道这些的正确缩写是什么，但它们还没有 Wi-Fi 和
stuff like you're saying just yet. Got it. Yeah, that makes sense. All right. My next news story is Fi3 Vision release. So a bit of background here. Microsoft has been pushing, well, a lot of things,
你说的那种东西。明白了。是的，这很有道理。好了。我的下一个新闻故事是 Phi-3 Vision 发布。这里有一点背景。微软一直在推动，嗯，很多东西，
but among them, these SML, or no, wait, SLM, Small Language Model. And so the idea is, you know, this is a model that I actually have one running right now on my phone. And it's pretty good, you know, this is a model that I actually have one running right now on my phone. And it's pretty good. You know, it runs in real time on my Samsung. It's not even really the latest model or anything. So small model, you know, it will give you some weird
但其中之一是这些 SML，或者不，等等，SLM，小语言模型。所以想法是，你知道，这是一个我手机上现在正在运行的模型。它相当不错，你知道，这是一个我手机上现在正在运行的模型。它相当不错。你知道，它在我的三星手机上实时运行。它甚至不是最新的模型。所以小模型，你知道，它肯定会给你一些奇怪的
answers for sure. You know, it definitely doesn't have the depth of these other models. But for general queries, it works pretty well. I had something recently. Oh, yeah. So there was some issue with Verizon. We ended up having to call Verizon, our cell phone company, and get it sorted out. But for whatever reason, my entire family lost internet, which was actually kind of terrifying. When you're on vacation we're on vacation and and and we just we still could make phone calls and texts and everything but we lost the actual
答案。你知道，它肯定没有其他模型那么深。但对于一般查询，它工作得很好。我最近遇到了一些事情。哦，是的。Verizon 出了点问题。我们最终不得不给 Verizon，我们的手机公司打电话，解决它。但不管什么原因，我们全家都断网了，这实际上有点可怕。当你在度假时，我们正在度假，我们仍然可以打电话和发短信，但我们失去了实际的
internet you know uh you know mobile data um and so i was you know downloading maps when i was on wi-fi and all those is a mess but but one of the things i did is i was asking this phi 3 because it was local on my phone just for some general queries and it was giving me answers. So it's amazing. And so now they released PHY3 Vision, which is an actual like multimodal model that you can run locally pretty easily. So people have done a lot of really interesting things with this. You can actually, um, I have a friend who took a photo of his driver's license and asked five, three vision, um, Hey, pull out the birthday and the driver's license number and the person's name
互联网，你知道，移动数据。所以我当时在 Wi-Fi 下下载地图，所有这些都是一团糟。但其中一件事是我问这个 Phi-3，因为它在我的手机上本地运行，只是为了做一些一般查询，它给了我答案。所以这太神奇了。现在他们发布了 Phi-3 Vision，这是一个真正的多模态模型，你可以很容易地在本地运行。所以人们用它做了很多非常有趣的事情。你实际上可以……我有一个朋友拍了他驾照的照片，问 Phi-3 Vision：“嘿，从这张照片里提取出生日期、驾照号码和姓名。”
out of this photo. Um, you know, and it did all of that and stole his identity so it's uh i'm just kidding um but no he ran it locally and so you know he's totally safe he knew that it wouldn't uh hit the cloud or anything like that with his driver's license um you know he gave it a few other pdfs and asked it to uh you know extract information and he said it was amazing. He said everything came out flawless. So I think this is just, I think, really something to pay attention to. There are better models like Lava, which is a multimodal model. But these require GPUs with 16 gigs RAM or maybe more than that. and so they're heavier models um it's really interesting to see like for an average person with an average desktop laptop
你知道，它完成了所有这些，偷了他的身份。所以这……我只是开个玩笑。但没有，他在本地运行它，所以你知道，他是完全安全的，他知道它不会连接云端或类似的东西。你知道，他给了它其他一些 PDF，让它提取信息，他说这太神奇了。他说一切都完美无缺。所以我认为这确实是值得关注的事情。有更好的模型，比如 LLaVA，这是一个多模态模型。但这些需要 16GB 内存或更多的 GPU，所以它们是更重的模型。看到普通人拿着普通的台式机、笔记本电脑
or even a phone you know what are what are we capable of doing here um this is uh really taking that to the next level so you can check it out it's it's pretty easy to download. And there's something, I'll put it in the show notes called O-Lama, where it will basically hold your hand and you don't need to be even an engineer or a coder to use these models. It gives you a like chat GPT like web interface, but for open source models.
甚至手机，我们能做什么，这真的很有趣。这确实将其提升到了一个新的水平。所以你可以去看看，下载它很容易。还有一件事，我会把它放在节目笔记里，叫 Ollama，它基本上会手把手教你，你甚至不需要成为工程师或程序员就能使用这些模型。它给你一个类似 ChatGPT 的网页界面，但针对的是开源模型。
So this is a super low barrier of entry and i think there's a ton of potential here so if you're out there you know college high school just getting started um you know check this out i think there's some real powerful stuff you could build on this very nice i haven't i do have a couple apps that that will run open source i think hugging face there's an app i don't know if it's an official app or not, but lets you from your phone hit those. Those aren't local though, but yeah, it is kind of cool to try the various ones
所以这是一个门槛极低的入口，我认为这里有巨大的潜力。所以如果你是大学生、高中生，刚开始接触，去看看这个，我认为你可以基于此构建一些非常强大的东西。非常好。我确实有几个可以运行开源模型的应用。我想 Hugging Face 有一个应用，我不知道它是不是官方的，但可以让你从手机上访问它们。那些不是本地的，但确实，尝试各种模型并看看它们如何工作或不工作，这很酷。
and see various ways you do or don't, that they can kind of fall over. But the multimodal stuff is cool. To dovetail it right into my next one, talking about multimodal is OpenAI. I mean, news all the time these days, controversies and new releases, but just focusing on a new release, release chat GPT for O, which the O being Omni and sort of their take on this multi multimodal.
多模态的东西很酷。为了顺便引出我的下一个话题，谈到多模态，就是 OpenAI。我的意思是，这些天新闻不断，争议和新发布，但只关注一个新发布，发布了 ChatGPT-4o，其中的“o”代表 Omni，这是他们对多模态的看法。
So doing being able to use pictures or voice, the demos are really cool. Sometimes a bit hard to recreate the demos uh if you try it yourself but in general pretty exciting to say like you know hey i'm sitting here with someone who speaks russian i only speak english like i'm going to speak english and i want you to translate it to russian they speak russian you know just describing you're like oh i could do that with the translator app it's like yeah but now you don't need to like you know for arbitrary configurations you know it can kind of understand but also some of the behind the scenes things that they're sort of saying that you know running this new version
所以能够使用图片或语音，演示非常酷。有时如果你自己尝试，很难重现演示，但总的来说，说“嘿，我坐在这里，有人说俄语，我只会说英语，我要说英语，我希望你把它翻译成俄语，他们说俄语”非常令人兴奋。你知道，描述起来就像“哦，我可以用翻译应用做到这一点”，就像“是的，但现在你不需要了”。对于任意配置，它都能理解。而且还有一些幕后情况，他们说运行这个新版本
even though it's improved it's just like orders of magnitude cheaper they're figuring out not really i mean you can kind of read the rumors about next version of you know chat gpt5 but it's kind of cool to see them get more and more efficient at running their current generation stuff sort of almost faster than you would expect. And it's just interesting to see how quickly things are moving
即使它有所改进，它也只是便宜了几个数量级。他们正在弄清楚……并不是真的，我的意思是你可以读到关于下一代 ChatGPT-5 的传闻，但看到他们运行当前一代东西的效率越来越高，速度几乎比你预期的还要快，这很酷。看到事情发展得如此之快，
and how the pace goes for training and running a lot of these models. Yeah, definitely. I'm a really big fan. I think, you know, they started, OpenAI started by doing reinforcement learning, which is obviously near and dear to my heart. I don't think, I don't know if they do much of that anymore, but still, I'm or stealing data from the internet. They've stolen all of my code, but that's okay because I stole it from Stack Overflow. So I copy pasted it first.
以及训练和运行这些模型的发展速度，这很有趣。是的，绝对。我是个大粉丝。我认为，你知道，他们开始时，OpenAI 是通过强化学习起步的，这显然是我心头所好。我不认为……我不知道他们现在是否还做很多那种事情，但仍然……或者从互联网上窃取数据。他们窃取了我所有的代码，但这没关系，因为我是从 Stack Overflow 偷来的。所以我先复制粘贴了它。
So how can I hold them responsible? So I think, well, I mean, that's a whole rabbit hole around data. And if you scrape Reddit, are you like you know trouble or whatever but but either way i mean i think it's amazing yeah this this uh i think the 40 the chat gbt 40 stands for omni because of the multimodal part um and uh i think there's so many interesting ways you could take this i mean you know one thing that just came to mind is, you know, you could run, Oh, circling back to what some of you said earlier, uh, the app that lets you actually run the models on your phone is called MLC chat. And, uh, you can get that. I think it's on iOS and Android. Um, but, uh, but yeah, imagine like you, you take a picture of like, uh, even just a restaurant receipt and it keeps track of what things you've eaten at restaurants.
所以我怎么能让他们负责呢？所以我认为，嗯，我的意思是，这是一个关于数据的巨大陷阱。如果你抓取 Reddit，你会有麻烦吗？但无论如何，我的意思是，我认为这太神奇了。是的，我认为 4o 中的“o”代表 Omni，因为多模态部分。而且我认为你可以通过很多有趣的方式来利用这一点。我的意思是，刚才想到的一件事是，你可以运行……哦，回到你们之前说的一些话，那个让你在手机上实际运行模型的应用叫 MLC Chat。而且，你可以得到它。我想它在 iOS 和 Android 上都有。但是，想象一下，你拍了一张餐厅收据的照片，它就能跟踪你在餐厅吃的东西。
I think there's a whole bunch of cool stuff you could do with this. And we'll have to see where people take it. All right. Time for book of the show. My book of the show is not a book. Spoiler alert. My book of the show is not a book. Spoiler alert, my tool of the show is also not a tool. Book of the show is a podcast. This is a bit of a different podcast.
我认为你可以用这个做很多很酷的事情。我们得看看人们会把它带向何方。好了，节目推荐书的时间到了。我的节目推荐书不是一本书。剧透警告。我的节目推荐书不是一本书。剧透警告，我的节目推荐工具也不是一个工具。节目推荐书是一个播客。这是一个有点不同的播客。
And I don't want to give like a ton of disclaimers. I've been enjoying listening to it. It's the My First Million podcast. This is like two business folks who are kind of like doing marketing, but they have interviews with people who have sort of done startups or sold companies. And they talk a little bit about details about, you know, kind of exact dollars they were earning and how marketing goes. They were talking to someone recently who had a blog about gardening and then started selling products and turn it into what I find it interesting is, it makes you think a lot about, you know, stuff that's pretty different, but adjacent to the
我不想给出太多的免责声明。我一直很喜欢听它。它是《My First Million》播客。这就像两个商业人士，他们有点像在做营销，但他们采访了一些创办过初创公司或卖过公司的人。他们谈论了一些关于他们赚了多少钱以及营销是如何进行的细节。他们最近采访了一个人，他有一个关于园艺的博客，然后开始销售产品，并把它变成了……我发现有趣的是，它让你思考很多关于……你知道，非常不同但与……相邻的事情。
stuff we do. I think a lot of software engineers always have this question about entrepreneurial pursuits, and like what the various trade offs, these folks are out talking to, you know, people who have done massive things, people who've have done small things and also just their observations it's a very casual podcast um a bit long-winded they also don't necessarily get to the topic of the podcast until late into the podcast um but uh you know they they release twice a week and it's it's a very casual listen i've been enjoying it i don't know that i'll listen to for you know always and ongoing but it's been good to sort of uh listen to kind, you know, always and ongoing, but it's been good to sort of listen to kind of the sales aspect, marketing, the kind of parts of the business that I don't normally focus on, right? I'm always thinking about solving hard problems and machine learning models or whatever, right?
我们所做的事情。我想很多软件工程师对创业追求总是有这样的疑问，比如各种权衡是什么。这些人出去和那些做过大事的人、做过小事的人交谈，也分享他们的观察。这是一个非常随意的播客，嗯，有点冗长，而且他们不一定会在播客后期才谈到主题，但是，你知道，他们每周发布两次，这是一个非常随意的收听体验。我一直很喜欢它，我不知道我会不会一直听下去，但能够了解销售方面、市场营销以及我通常不关注的业务部分，这很好，对吧？我总是专注于解决难题、机器学习模型之类的东西，对吧？
Like those things are much more up my avenue. This is adjacent and people doing often software businesses, but talking about motivations and things you know related to personnel and you know how to relate to people and anyways personally i've just been finding it a nice orthogonal set of views i guess to to what i might normally pay attention to yeah that's awesome um yeah i'll have to check this out jason freed that name sounds familiar is he the base camp person or is that somebody else yeah he was one of the ones uh him and dhh or whatever yeah okay there we go yeah very cool yeah i'm definitely going to check that out it looks like fun um all right so totally on the other end of the spectrum my book is the one of the geekiest books i think we've had on the
像那些事情更符合我的方向。这与此相关，人们通常从事软件业务，但谈论动机以及与人员相关的事情，你知道，如何与人相处。总之，我个人觉得这是一组很好的正交观点，与我通常关注的内容相比，我想是的。那太棒了，嗯，我得去看看。杰森·弗里德（Jason Fried），这个名字听起来很耳熟，他是Basecamp的那个人吗，还是别人？是的，他是其中之一，他和DHH之类的。好的，明白了，太酷了，我一定要去看看，看起来很有趣。好吧，完全在另一个极端，我的书是我认为我们节目中最极客的书之一。
show it's this research paper from yan lacoon um that he wrote in 2022 called a path towards autonomous machine intelligence i have a link to the pdf um in in the show notes um It's not a, it's not a, called a, an approved paper. It wasn't submitted to any conferences. It's just an open paper that's written on open review. And you can kind of tell, you know, there's some languages,
这是杨立昆（Yann LeCun）在2022年写的一篇研究论文，名为《迈向自主机器智能的路径》。我在节目笔记中提供了PDF的链接。它不是一篇经过批准的论文。它没有提交给任何会议。它只是一篇写在OpenReview上的开放论文。你可以看出来，你知道，有一些语言错误、语法错误，或者一些含糊其辞的内容。实际上，我认为它甚至没有结果部分。但有时这些是最好的论文，你知道，这只是人们原始的想法，所以这篇
you know, errors, grammatical errors, or some hand wavy stuff. There aren't really any, actually, I think there's literally no results section. But sometimes these are the best papers you know it's just like raw thoughts of of of folks and so this
论文真的很有趣，它试图将，嗯，你知道，这些非常大的潜在模型联系起来，对吧？所以，大型语言模型，而且我认为我们开始使用基础模型，因为它们是多模态的，但是，你知道，这些基础模型是前向模型，这意味着它们向前看。所以它说，你知道，鉴于我刚刚写了这段话的一部分，我接下来应该写什么词，或者我接下来应该写哪几个词。嗯，所以你可以将其扩展到任何事情，你可以说，嗯，你知道，鉴于我在国际象棋中走了这一步，我接下来应该走哪一步，或者鉴于我在车里这样转动方向盘，你知道，我接下来应该对车做什么，所以这里有一种
this paper is really interesting it tries to tie together um uh you know these these uh really large latent models right so so large language models, and I think we're starting to use foundational models because they are multimodal, but you know, these foundational models are, you know, forward models, which means they look ahead. So it says, you know, given I just wrote this part of a paragraph, what's the next word I should write, or what's the next handful of words I should write. Um, and so you could extend that to really anything you could say well uh you know given that i made this move in chess what's the next move i should make or given that i turn the steering wheel this way in this in this you know uh car you know what should i do next with the car um so so there's sort of like a
万物理论的东西在发生，你知道，想法是你建立这个巨大的世界模型，试图预测未来。然后你做各种不同的事情，比如采样和一些基于梯度的搜索，以及不同的方法来搜索潜在的未来。所以我的意思是，也许退一步，你有你所处的世界，想象一下，这是一个我们可以用来解决的好问题，比如，让我们以国际象棋为例，怎么样？好的，让我们以国际象棋为例，而不是像计算机预期的那样给你一个棋盘，你得到的是棋盘的照片。所以你必须通过看棋盘的照片来下棋。有很多事情真的不重要，对吧？比如，如果棋子因为有新的光源而开始向相反方向投下阴影，那与你试图解决的问题无关，对吧？
theory of everything kind of thing going on here where, you know, the idea is you build this massive world model that, that tries to predict the future. And then you do a variety of different things like sampling and some gradient based, uh, search and different methods to search through potential futures so i mean maybe taking a step back so you have the the world you're in imagine you are it's a good problem we can use for this um like uh just let's take chess for example what about okay let's take chess where instead of you know you getting a chess board the way a computer would expect it, you're getting pictures of a chess board. And so you have to play chess from looking at pictures of a chess board. There's a lot of things that really don't matter, right? Like if the pieces start casting a shadow in the opposite direction because there's a new light source, that's not relevant
所以如果你看ChatGPT，ChatGPT是在获取文本并试图产生更多文本。所以它确实必须理解关于文本的一切。但在这种情况下，你并不是真的在获取一张棋盘的照片并试图用你的走法创建一张棋盘的照片。你是在试图获取一个棋盘并做出走法。对吧。所以那里有很多混淆信息，比如阴影。所以这里的想法是你创建一个嵌入，或者像图像的低级投影。
to the problem you're trying to solve, right? And so if you look at ChatGBT, ChatGBT is taking text and trying to produce more text. So it really has to understand everything about text. But in this case, you're not really taking in a picture of a chessboard and trying to create a picture of the chessboard with your move on it. You're trying to take in a chessboard and make the move. Right. And so there's a lot of confounding information there, like shadows, for example. So so the idea here is you you create like an embedding or like a low level projection of the image.
然后你尝试用你的走法来预测图像的低级预测。所以想象一下我说，这是一张棋盘的照片。我想要你给我一张棋子向上移动了一格的棋盘照片。所以，与其字面渲染那张照片（这需要很多浪费的时间），它创建了这种低维表示，然后是棋子在新的位置的棋盘的低维表示。然后你可以做的是，你可以物理移动那个棋子，拍一张照片，然后嵌入那张照片，看看它是否有效。那么未来的嵌入是否与现在的嵌入加上这个应该将其带入未来的函数相匹配？
And then you try to predict the low level prediction of the image with your move in it. So imagine I say, here's a picture of a chessboard. And I want you to give me a picture of the chessboard where the pawn has been moved up a square. And so but instead of literally rendering that photo, which, you know, requires a lot of wasted time, it creates sort of this low dimensional presentation and then a low directional representation of the board with the pawn in the new spot. And then what you could do is you could physically move that pawn, take a picture, and then embed that picture and see if it worked. So did the embedding of the future match the embedding of the present
你会很快注意到，你可以破解这个，或者你可以利用这个。你可以说，哦，我的嵌入只是零向量，所有的动作都把零向量变成零向量。所以我嵌入到零向量，我移动棋子，现在我有零向量，我嵌入未来，这也是零向量。我移动棋子。现在我有零向量。我嵌入未来，这也是零向量。果然，零向量等于零向量。看起来我的嵌入很棒，但实际上它什么有用的事情都没做，对吧？他们绕过这个问题的方法（我觉得非常非常聪明）是，我看我能不能简单地解释一下。
plus this function that's supposed to take it into the future? And one thing that you'll quickly notice is'll quickly notice is like you can hack this or you could you could um exploit this you could say oh well my embedding is just the zero vector and all actions just turn the zero vector into the zero vector and so so i embed to the zero vector i move the pawn now i have the zero vector i embed the future which is also the zero vector. I move the pawn. Now I have the zero vector. I embed the future, which is also the zero vector. And sure enough, the zero vector equals a zero vector. And it could seem like my embedding is amazing, but actually it's not doing anything useful, right? And the way they get around that, which I thought was super, super clever, was I'm going to see if I can explain this easily.
他们试图最大化嵌入的信息。他们这样做的方法是，你知道，如果你有一张照片，对吧？它是，我们过去在节目中谈论过这个，它是每个像素的小RGB值，对吧？所以它就像一吨这些RGB值。对吧。嗯，
They try to maximize the information of the embedding. And the way they do it is, you know, if you have a picture, right? It's, and we've talked about this on the show in the past, like it's little RGB values for each pixel, right? And so it's like a ton of these like RGB values. Right. Um,
然后当你把它压碎成这个嵌入时，现在它就像少量的数字或维度，但它试图完成某种目标。在他的例子中，目标是做我们谈到的这个前向的事情，但他还希望参数的方差尽可能高。所以基本上，嗯，试图用一种花哨的方式说，试图让数字在一张棋盘照片到另一张之间有很大的变化。所以如果你拍了一堆棋盘的照片，它们都坍缩成相同的嵌入，你可以假设它做得不好。
and then when you crush it down into this embedding, now it's like a small number of, of numbers or dimensions, but it's trying to like accomplish some goal. And the goal in his case is to do this forward thing we talked about but also he wants the variance of the parameters to be as high as possible so basically um trying to make fancy way of saying trying to make the numbers vary a lot from one picture of a chessboard to another. So if you take a bunch of pictures of chessboards and they all collapse to the same embedding, you could assume that it's not doing a good job.
现在，可能什么都没变，但也可能你没有很好地捕捉信息。所以是的，这只是论文的一部分。我的意思是，这是一份50页的报告。所以这里有很多内容。我喜欢这一点的是，你真的不需要知道代数和对微分方程的一些理解之外的任何东西就能掌握它。它没有引用一百万篇你需要去阅读的其他论文。所以我认为这是那些了解微分方程的人，或者即使你不了解，也可以阅读这篇论文并从中获得很多东西的事情之一。
Now, it's possible that nothing has changed, but it's also possible that you're not doing a good job of capturing information. So yeah, that's just part of the paper. I mean, this is a 50-page report. So there's a lot of content here. The thing I like about this is you don't really need to know anything beyond just algebra and some understanding of differential equations to grasp this. It doesn't refer to a million other papers that you then have to go read. So I think it's one of these things that folks who know Diffie Q, or even if you don't, you could read this paper
这是一个很好的入门论文，但内容也很多。这是他观点的一部分。我的意思是，我想他谈到过这一点，但目前的机器学习东西，比如LLM，并不能真正进行规划。它不能弄清楚如何做事情。
and get a lot out of it. It's a good kind of starter paper, but there's a lot of content too. And this is part of his thing. I mean, I think he's talked about this, but the contention that the current machine learning stuff, like the LLMs, can't really do planning. It can't sort of figure out how to do stuff.
它可以描述计划的文本，但它本身并不进行规划，因为它不像你谈论的那样在空间中移动。这与此有关。是的，是的，那是对的，是的，是的。所以，你知道，他实际上在推特上很有名地写道，嗯，如果你现在在大学，如果你现在正在攻读博士学位，不要费心去搞LLM，因为公司都在搞这个。他说，去做LLM之后的事情，我认为这是绝对正确的。
It can describe the text of a plan, but it itself doesn't do planning because it doesn't sort of move through the space like you're talking about. And this is related to that. Yeah yeah that's right yep yep so you know he actually famously put on twitter um like uh if you're in college right now if you're getting a phd right now don't bother with llms because like the companies are all over it he's like do the thing after llms um which i think is absolutely correct.
就像我们在节目开始时谈到的那个LinkedIn的事情，比如采用LLM，并支持他在这篇论文中谈到的其他一些方法。非常好。是的，如果你一直关注，我想是X，最近埃隆·马斯克（Elon Musk）和Yann LeCun之间在互相攻击，关于成为科学家和撰写论文的事情。总之，如果你想要一些戏剧性，请随意去阅读那个帖子。是的，完全正确。好了，现在是节目工具时间，正如预示的那样，被剧透了，我的不是节目工具，而是一个游戏。这个游戏我想实际上在各种游戏机上都有，Xbox、PlayStation，但我一直在我的Steam Deck上玩，那就是《潜水员戴夫》（Dave the Diver）。这就像那种事情，如果你告诉别人你在玩一个游戏，你是一个身材稍微走样的鱼叉潜水渔夫，白天去收集鱼，晚上经营一家寿司店。
Like this LinkedIn thing we talked about at the beginning of the show, like take an LLM and these things in favor of some of these other approaches that he talks about in the paper. Very nice. Yeah, if you have been paying attention to, I guess, X, is that recently there was shade being thrown between Elon Musk and Yk and and yann lecun about about being being scientists and writing papers and anyways feel free to go read that that thread if you want some drama yeah exactly all right it's time for tool of the show as uh foreshadowed spoiled mine is not a tool to show but it is a game um this game is available i think on actually various consoles um xbox playstation but also um i've been playing on my Steam Deck and that's Dave the Diver. It's just like one of those things if you tell someone you're playing a game where you're like a slightly out of shape spear diving fisherman who goes and collects fish and then runs a sushi restaurant by night.
那听起来就像，什么？但它实际上很有效。它很有趣。而且它是一个，我想你会称之为，我不会，我无论如何都会误用这个词。它有点像Roguelike游戏，因为你有一种反复下潜和捕鱼的循环。
It would just be like, what? But it actually works. It's kind of fun. And it's a, I guess you would call that, I'm not, I'm gonna misuse this from anyways. It's a bit of a rogue-like game in that you sort of have the cycle of going down and doing the fishing repeatedly.
你不是为了赢它。你只是在进步。你在下潜和捕鱼方面可以做得更好或更差。但随后你经历了供应寿司、赚钱和升级装备的循环，然后你可以再去，你可以学习，你知道，获得帮助你潜得更深、拥有更好武器并抵御海里试图吃掉你的东西的装备。所以游戏就这样进行着。我还没有通关，假设有一个结局，我还没有到那里。
You're not meant to sort of win it. You're just progressing. And you can do better or worse at going down and catching the fish. But then you go through the cycle of serving the sushi and earning money and upgrading your equipment and then you can go again and you can learn you know get equipment that helps you dive deeper and have better weapons and fend off you know things trying to eat you in the sea um and so the game sort of sort of progresses i've not beaten it presuming that there is a an end game i've not gotten there
还没，嗯，而且它还有一个故事，我不会剧透。但这只是那种有趣的，你不需要玩很长时间。对于如何排列你的鱼叉并射出鱼叉，控制方式做得相当巧妙。如果你不喜欢，我想是虐鱼，绝对要远离。我的意思是，它确实涉及吃寿司，所以它必须以某种方式获得。但是，嗯，你知道，绝对是一个有趣的游戏，做得很好。艺术是一种像素艺术风格，所以它很有趣。但游戏玩法很酷，你知道，如果你只有五分钟时间玩，你可以去潜水一次之类的。
yet um still and there is a story along with it that i won't i won't spoil um but it's just sort of like a fun never you don't have to really play for a long time the controls are kind of cleverly done for how to sort of line up your spear and and shoot your spear out if you're not into i guess fish cruelty definitely stay away i mean it does involve eating sushi so it has to be procured somehow um but uh you know definitely like a fun game well done like the art is kind of a pixel art style so uh it's it's kind of fun that way um but the gameplay just is cool and you know if you only have like five minutes to play you can go on one of the dives or whatever
你可以玩更长时间，但你不必坐下来想，好吧，我要投入90分钟。所以我一直很喜欢它。当你死的时候会发生什么？如果一条鱼真的吃了他，他怎么活到第二天？所以我认为它只是对那部分挥手告别了。所以如果你在收集鱼，并且你携带的数量有限制，比如重量，你死了，你就会失去你携带的一切。但我假设他有某种，我不知道我是否记得他们是如何挥手告别你回到船上并可以再试一次的事实的。明白了，好的，那很酷，我得去看看。我听说过那个游戏的好评，所以我得去看看。是的，我很怀疑，但它很有效。太酷了，好的，我的节目工具也是一个游戏，但非常非常相关。
you can play for longer but you don't have to like sit down and be like okay i'm putting 90 minutes into this um and so i've been enjoying that what happens when you die like how does he make it to the next day if a fish literally eats him so i i mean i think it just sort of hand waves over that part so if you're collecting up fish and there's like a limit to how many you can carry like a weight that you die like you lose everything you're carrying but i i i presume he has some sort i don't know that i remember exactly how they hand wave away the fact that you return to the boat and you can try again got it okay that's cool i'll have to check i've heard good things about that game so i'll have to check it out yeah i was very skeptical but it works very cool all right my my uh tool of the show is also a game, but very, very relevant.
它叫《图灵完备》（Turing Complete）。我从这个游戏中了解了很多关于底层工程的知识，比如电气工程，我想，或者计算机工程。所以字面意思上，他们给你的第一关，帕特里克，你会知道这个，他们基本上给你一个门，你必须构建所有其他的，我想是与非门，对吧？好的，是的，他们给你一个与非门，他们说，做一个非门，他们说，做一个或门，做一个与门，然后
It's called Turing Complete. And I learned a ton about low-level engineering, like electrical engineering, I guess, or computer engineering from this game. So literally, the first level they give you, and Patrick, you're going to know this, they basically give you one of the gates, and you have to build all the others i think nand no right okay yeah they give you a nand gate and they're like make a not gate they're like make an or gate make an and gate and
嗯，所以你从一个与非门构建所有的门，然后当你构建东西时，它们最终会出现在你的工具栏上，因为它是非常模块化的，对吧？所以就像，好的，现在我不需要制作非门了，一旦我构建了它，我现在就有了它。然后你一直走到你构建寄存器，你构建一个算术逻辑单元（ALU），然后你最终创建你自己的汇编代码。所以你学习，在开始时，他们给你没有参数的汇编代码。所以你字面意思上必须像，如果你要从这个寄存器移动内存到那个寄存器，你需要为所有可能的寄存器对有一个命名的指令。然后它给你像带参数的汇编代码，你可以只像有一个移动操作符或像多符号，
um and so you build all the gates from a nand gate and then as you build things um they end up on your toolbar so because it's very modular right so it's like okay now i don't need to make the not gate as soon as i build it i just have it now um and then you get all the way to where you like build registers and you build like an alu and then you end up like up creating your own assembly code. So you learn, in the beginning, they give you assembly code without arguments. So you literally have to be like, if you're moving memory from this register to that register, you need to have a named instruction for all possible pairs of registers. And then it gives you like assembly code with arguments where you could just have like a move operator or like multi-symbol,
我想，汇编代码。最后，你最终创建了射击小行星、解决迷宫和做各种疯狂事情的东西。你玩太空侵略者。你构建一个AI来玩太空侵略者，而且你可以实际上然后像钻研，你可以构建AI来玩太空侵略者，如果你有兴趣，钻研到你构建的这台计算机中的单个与非门。这令人难以置信地满足，它实际上教会了
I guess, assembly code. And then in the end, you end up like creating things that shoot down asteroids and solving mazes and doing all sorts of crazy stuff. You play a space invaders. You build an ai to play space invaders um and like you can actually then like drill down like you could build the ai to play space invaders and if you're inclined drill all the way down to like an individual nand gate in this computer you built um it is unbelievably satisfying it actually taught
我很多，因为正如人们所知，计算机工程不是我的背景，所以，嗯，我通过做它学到了很多。它变得非常非常难，你知道，我能够通关整个游戏，但是，嗯，我认为我会说中后期对于没有工程学位的人来说基本上是无法进入的。我不知道我是不是把我的技能看得太高了，但我感觉如果一个人在游戏的最后几关会遇到很大的困难。但这没关系，因为你已经体验了太多的内容。也许这会鼓励人们去获得四年制学位之类的。但有很多复杂性，但非常有趣。UI做得非常好，你放置电路的方式。
me a lot because as people know um like computer engineering is not my background and so um i learned a lot by doing it um it gets really really hard um you know i was able to get through the whole game but but um i i think it's i would say the mid to end game is pretty much inaccessible for people without an engineering degree. I don't know if I'm just like taking my skills too highly there, but I feel like if I feel like a person is going to have a really hard time with the last few levels of this game. But that's OK, because you've experienced so much of the content already. And maybe it would encourage people to go and get like a four-year degree or something. But there's a lot of complexity, but a ton of fun. The UI is really well done, the way you place the circuits.
你可以对轨迹进行颜色编码等等。强烈推荐。绝对值得……我不认为它甚至那么贵，绝对值得那20美元。我想我们之前顺便提过那个，但这绝对是一个很好的评论。我还没有尝试过，所以现在你让我想要去做了，但我知道我也会因为做过几次那种自下而上的事情而讨厌自己，在几种不同的背景下，痛苦和折磨，并且知道，是的，如果你已经知道触发器是如何工作的，你可以查一下，但你
And you can color code the traces and everything. Highly recommend it. Definitely worth the... I don't think it's even that expensive definitely worth the 20 bucks i think we mentioned that one in passing before but this is like definitely a good review review of it i've not tried it so now now you make me like want to go do it but i know i'll also hate myself having done that bottoms up thing a few times in a few different contexts uh the pain and the suffering uh and knowing that like yes you can just look up how a flip-flop works if you already know what a flip-flop is um but you're
应该从头开始再弄清楚它。是的，我尽了最大努力完全不作弊。有件事，我想是像异或门之类的，其中一个门我觉得有一个非常简单的解决方案，但我有一个非常复杂的解决方案，因为我不想作弊。好的，进入主题，DevOps或开发运维。帕特里克，什么是DevOps？好的，这是一个公平的问题。所以词汇很难，但你知道，DevOps我认为是在从编译代码、测试代码、部署代码，将代码的生命周期从开发到生产，以及围绕此的过程的责任集合中。是的，那是对的。我也这么觉得。我听说过站点可靠性工程师（SRE）。那是什么？那和DevOps一样吗？它们不同吗？所以这是一个公平的问题。我不得不仔细检查以确保我对这个的思考是好的，因为有时你会得到一个经验定义，而不是一个实际定义。所以我认为SRE是一个源于谷歌的术语，但已经获得了认可。站点可靠性工程师负责基本上保持生产运行和工作。所以两者在某些方面确实有重叠，但SRE负责生产环境。所以确保事情，数据库保持高性能，网站保持运行，监控流量，如果有什么东西宕机了就发出警报，
supposed to figure it out again from scratch yeah i i did my that was another thing is i did my best to not cheat at all um there was something um i think it was like an x or gate or something there one of these gates were like i felt like there's an incredibly simple solution but i had an incredibly convoluted solution because i didn't want to cheat all right on to the topic devops or developer operations uh patrick what is devops all right this is this is a fair question uh so words are hard uh but but you know devops i think is in the set of responsibilities that take you from compiling your code testing your code deploying your code the sort of life cycle of your code into an application from development and into production
要么自己重启它、修复它，要么让工程师或DevOps参与其中。所以DevOps如果做得不好，确实会让SRE的工作变得更难。但SRE确实是最终负责保持它运行的人。是的，是的，是的。那是对的。是的。而且DevOps非常非常重要。你知道，停机，我的意思是，取决于你在哪里工作，停机可能会也可能不会上新闻。它们绝对会对你的公司产生巨大的影响。如果人们觉得他们不能信任你的公司一直在线，那就会产生问题。我的意思是，正如我所说，当我们度假时，我们失去了移动数据，产生了巨大的影响。我们想到的事情之一是也许我们不应该
and the processes that go around that. Yeah, that's right. I feel the same way. I've heard of site reliability engineer. What is that? Is that the same as DevOps? Are they different? So this is a fair question. I had to double check just to make sure my thinking around this was good, because sometimes you end up with a experiential definition versus a, you know, actual definition. So I think SRE is a term that started out of Google, but has gained acceptance. And a site reliability engineer is responsible for basically keeping production up and working. And so the two do have, in some ways, overlap, but SREs are responsible for the production environment. So making sure that things, databases are staying performant, websites are staying up, monitoring traffic, alerting if something goes down,
让整个家庭使用一个计划。我的意思是，我们仍然会这样做，因为否则会非常麻烦，但这让我们思考了这一点，对吧？所以，我认为这会对你的业务、你公司的声誉产生巨大的影响。还有，你的工程时间，对吧？所以如果DevOps做得正确，那么你的工程师会得到非常快速的反馈。任何构建过东西的人都知道，你有没有回去看你一年前的代码？你会想，你知道是哪个白痴写了这个，这家伙需要被解雇，然后你看了文件顶部，那是你的名字，或者
and either restarting it, fixing it, whatever themselves, or involving engineers or DevOps and sort of that. So DevOps can definitely make an SRE's job a lot harder if they're not doing a good job helping to check along it. But SREs are really the people responsible for keeping it up and going in the end. Yep. Yep. Yep. That's right. Yeah. And DevOps is extremely, extremely important. You know, outages, I mean, depending on where you work, outages may or may not make the news. They definitely have a huge impact on your company. If people feel like they can't trust your company to be up all the time, that's going to create problems i mean as i said when we were on vacation and we lost mobile data had like a huge impact and one of the things we thought is maybe we shouldn't
什么，对吧？不，从来没做过，从来没发生过。所以，你知道，如果有一个你三个月没发现的问题，你知道，你失去了上下文，你转向了别的事情。如果你有一个问题，你在五分钟内发现了，嗯，那完全是另一回事，你可以很快纠正它。最坏的情况，你可以回滚。即使你不知道是什么原因造成的，你至少可以回滚五分钟，然后说，好的，让我们花点时间弄清楚这一点。如果这是一个可能已经存在三个月的问题，而人们现在才开始遇到它，那对你的工程团队和你自己来说可能压力极大。
have the entire family on one plan um i mean we're we're still going to do that because it'd be a huge hassle otherwise but it made us think about that right so like that so i think it can have a huge impact on your business um your company's reputation. Also, your engineering time, right? So if DevOps is done correctly, then your engineers are getting very quick feedback. Anyone who's built something knows, you ever go back and look at your code from a year ago? You're like, you you know what idiot wrote this like this guy needs to be fired and then you look at the top of the file and it's your name on it or
所以DevOps旨在解决所有这些问题。如果你正在做任何发送给其他人的软件，这绝对是至关重要的。是的，我的意思是，杰森提到了停机可能上新闻。但我的意思是，如果你想到像亚马逊宕机这样的事情，那可能是一笔荒谬的钱。每个人的角色在某种程度上都是确保这种情况不会发生。但即使在，像你提到的，在较小的公司里，如果，你知道，你试图，如果你弄不清楚为什么今天的东西表现得和昨天或前天不一样，而且，你因为我们将要谈论的一些技术而四处奔波，
something right no never done that never happened so um so you know that uh you know so if you if you have a problem that you don't find for three months um you know you've lost context you move on to something else um If you have a problem and you find out in five minutes, well, that's a totally different story and you can rectify that pretty quickly. At worst case, you can roll back. Even if you don't know what's causing it, you can at least roll back five minutes and just say, okay, let's take our time and figure this out. If it's a problem that's maybe been there for three months and people are just starting to hit it now, that can be extremely stressful for your engineering team and for yourself.
那，你知道，DevOps，不仅仅是一个特定的人或一群人，而是每个人都有责任去做其中涉及的一些事情，并真正确保你能快速弄清楚发生了什么。没有什么比撞墙更糟糕的了。如果你曾经遇到过，我的代码，我什么都没改，但它表现得完全不同，或者我改了这一行，一切都变了。这非常非常令人沮丧。如果你不小心，这可能不仅仅发生在你的编译中。是的，是的，是的。那是对的。所以是的，跳进去，也许我们只是开始。所以，你知道，一般的DevOps周期是，构建、测试、发布。所以我们将构建这个
So DevOps is meant to address all of these issues. And it's absolutely critical if you're doing any type of software that goes to other people. Yeah, I mean, Jason mentioned outages potentially making the news. But I mean, it can be an absurd amount of money if you think of something like Amazon going down. And everybody's role is to make sure that doesn't happen to some extent. But even in, like you mentioned, in smaller companies, if, if, you know, you're trying to, if you can't figure out why something is acting different today than it did yesterday or the day before, and like, you're doing a lot of running around because of some of the techniques that we're going to talk about,
剧集也是一样。所以看看那里的第一步，构建，你知道，构建你打算给别人或另一台机器的软件实际上非常难。你知道，我们过去谈论过这个，但你的机器上有一堆库。所以在这里退一步，你有你的操作系统，它有一堆核心C库。然后你有一堆你安装的包，操作系统包。然后其中一些包本身就是包管理器，比如Python的pip或npm。所以你有所有的上下文。所以如果你构建一个软件，它可能正在使用任何或所有这些上下文。然后你把那个软件给别人，或者给云中的机器，或者给客户。而那个软件不能工作，对吧？或者它不能按你预期的那样工作。所以这被称为，我总是很难说出这个名字，但它是幂等性（idempotency），幂等性。
that, you know, DevOps, not just being a specific person or group of people, but really everyone's responsibility to do some of the stuff that's involved in this and really making sure that you can quickly get to the bottom of what's going on. Nothing worse than banging your head. If you ever encountered that, my code, I haven't changed anything, but it's doing something completely different, or I changed this one line and everything is different. It's very, very frustrating. And that can happen in more than just your compiling if you're not careful. Yep. Yep. Yep. That's right. So yeah, jumping into it, maybe we'll just start. So, you know, the general DevOps cycle is, you know, build, test, release. And so we'll structure this
这意味着什么，如果它没有外部依赖，某物就是幂等的，对吧？所以想象一个不使用任何全局变量或系统调用之类的函数。是的，那个函数没有外部依赖。每次你调用二加二，你都会得到四，每次都是，无论上下文是什么，或者一天中的时间，任何类似的东西。所以你希望你的构建系统像那样。挑战在于，它变得有点像获得百分之百的测试覆盖率，变得极其困难，无法获得那么多的幂等性。例如，嗯，你知道，一个非常流行的构建软件的工具，你知道，至少在C、C++和Python中是Bazel。所以Bazel，
episode in the same way. So looking at the very first step there, building, you know, building software that you intend to give to someone else or to another machine is actually really hard. You know, we've talked about this in the past, but you have a bunch of libraries on your machine. So stepping back a bit here, you have your operating system, which has a bunch of core C libraries. Then you have a whole bunch of packages that you've installed, OS packages. And then some of those packages are themselves package managers, like Python's pip or nM. So you have all of that context. And so if you build a piece of software, it could be using any or all of that context. And then you give that software to somebody else or to a machine in the cloud, or to a customer. And and that software doesn't work, right, Or it doesn't work the way you intend. And so this is called, I always have a hard time saying this name, but it's idempotency, idempotency.
你实际上可以用Bazel做的是，你可以让Bazel构建它自己的，你知道，编译器，并让Bazel构建它自己的，你知道，C库等等。然后你有了，当它构建其他软件时，它正在使用那些它构建的编译器和C库。所以这是一种终极。我的意思是，我认为终极的幂等解决方案是Bazel运行在一个拥有空Linux镜像的Docker容器内。而在那个拥有空Linux镜像的Docker容器内。
And what that means is something is idempotent if it has no external dependencies, right? And so imagine like a function that doesn't use any global variables or system calls or anything yeah that function has no external dependencies every time you call two plus two you get four every single time no matter what the context is or time of day anything like that um and so you want your build system to be like that um the challenge is it's it becomes kind of uh like getting a hundred percent test coverage where it just becomes exceedingly difficult to to sort of get get that much uh idempotency so for example um you know one really popular tool for building software, you know, at least in C, C++, and Python is Bazel. So Bazel,
而在那个Docker容器内，Bazel去从头开始构建一切。现在，再次，这极其昂贵。那里有一堆挑战。实际执行它很难。所以对于大多数人来说，他们不需要走那么远。但只要知道，使用Bazel本身就是获得幂等性的一个很好的第一步。是的，我听说过这也被称为密封构建（hermetic builds），我不确定两者之间是否有细微的差别，但是，嗯，我认为就像你提到的，有第一
what you can actually do with Bazel is you can actually have Bazel build its own, you know, compiler and have Bazel build its own, you know, C libraries and all of that. And then you have, when it builds other software, it's using those compilers and C libraries that it built. And so that's kind of the ultimate. I mean, I think the ultimate idempotent solution is Bazel runs inside of a Docker container that has an empty Linux image. And inside that Docker container that has like an empty Linux image.
行的事情，就是，你知道，嘿，我们将所有库固定到一个已知版本，每个人都在同一个操作系统版本上，你可以获得99%的好处，你知道，如果事情在每个人之间是可重现的，但它可能仍然是，嗯，我试图想出一些具体的例子，但取决于你在构建中有什么，不仅仅是你的构建基础设施，如果你达到我想要输出二进制文件的哈希值在任何人的机器上构建时都是相同的水平。它字面意思上是位相同的，无论如何。那么你最终可能会得到各种各样的有趣的事情，这些事情被拾取或使用，或者事情的顺序。如果你真的，真的走到了极端，每个人的机器都构建一个位相同的
And inside that Docker container, Bazel goes and builds everything from the ground up. Now, again, that's extremely expensive. There's a bunch of challenges there. It's hard to actually execute that. And so for most people, they don't need to go that far. But just know just using basil at all is a good first step to um to get idempotency yeah i've heard this called hermetic builds as well i'm not sure if there's a slight difference between the two but um i think like you mentioned there's the first
二进制文件，这可能需要很多运行和确保事情完全如你所想。但拥有，你知道，正如杰森提到的，即使是从源代码构建也是一个巨大的解锁，但至少知道每个人都在使用的东西的版本绝对是非常有用的，以及每个人都依赖什么，因为如果你什么都不做，不仅你的构建不可重现，而且我在团队中遇到过这种情况。有人给你发了一些东西，你无法让它编译
line of things which is you know hey we pin all of the libraries to a known version everyone's on the same os version and you can get 99 to the benefits that you know if things are reproducible across everyone's but it still may be uh i'm trying to think of like some specific examples but depending on what you have in the build as well not just your build infrastructure if you go to the level of i want the you know hash of my output binaries to be identical no matter whose machine I build it on. It is literally a bit identical regardless. Then you can end up with all sorts of interesting things that are getting picked up or used or the ordering of things. If you really, really go to an extreme that everybody's machine builds a bit identical
因为有15个依赖项在任何地方都没有被调用，因为它们只是从他们的计算机上被拾取了。所以你需要一个一个地解决，你知道，brew install这个，pip install那个。你只是一个一个地去，你知道，brew install这个，pip install那个。你只是一个一个地去，你知道，试图找到要安装的包集合。这非常令人沮丧。是的，是的。是的，完全正确。嗯，所以，让它完全密封或幂等
binary, it can take a lot of running things down and making sure that things are exactly as you think they are. But the big unlock of having, you know, as Jason mentioned, even like building it from source is one, but at least knowing the version of something that everyone is on is definitely super useful and what everybody's depending on because if you do none of it at the opposite, it's not just that your builds aren't reproducible, but I've had this on Teams. Someone sends you something and you can't get it to compile
确实非常困难。嗯，一个很好的中间地带，我认为是最流行的方法，是拥有一个与你的生产硬件相匹配的构建服务器。所以想象一下，如果你正在将一个网站部署到AWS EC2实例，你可能不想在你的桌面上构建那个网站并复制它，可能想至少在另一个具有完全相同规格和硬件和软件设置的EC2实例上进行最终构建。这样你知道，如果有一个问题，假设你正在运行gcc 10和，嗯，或者像libc，你知道2.13，而他们在云上运行2.6，那么会发生什么，构建在你的机器上会工作得很好。但当你尝试在推送到客户之前进行最终构建时，那个最终构建会在这个EC2实例上发生，它会抛出一些错误，至少你会在它到达生产服务器之前捕获它。所以有一堆工具可以做到这一点，嗯，你知道
because there's 15 dependencies that aren't called out anywhere because they just got picked up from their computer. And so you need to one by one resolve, you know, brew install this, pip install that. And you're just going at it one by one by one, you know, brew, install this pip, install that. And you're just going at it one by one by one, you know, trying to find the set of packages to install. And it's super frustrating. Yep. Yep. Yeah, exactly. Um, so, you know, getting it completely hermetic or idempotent
这被称为构建农场或测试农场，有一堆工具可以做到这一点。我过去使用过Buildbarn，我也使用过Jenkins，嗯，现在有GitHub Actions，所以这些做，嗯，很多不同的事情。你可以通过触发器运行命令，但至少在Buildbarn的情况下，它也只是透明地连接到Bazel。所以它的工作方式是你配置你的Bazel，Bazel实际上有一个用于提交作业和获取结果返回的API。所以你可以设置Bazel指向一个Buildbarn实例，并说，嘿，你可以在我的机器上本地构建代码，但你也可以在这个Buildbarn实例上构建它。
is really difficult. Um, one thing that's a nice middle ground, which I think is the most popular approach, is to have a build server which matches your production hardware. So imagine if you are deploying a website to an AWS EC2 instance, you probably don't want to build that website on your desktop and copy it over probably want to do at least that final build on another ec2 instance with exactly the same specs and and heart and software setup um that way you know if there is a problem let's say you're running the gcc 10 and um or like libc you know 2.13 and they're running 2.6 on the cloud, then what will happen is the build will work fine on your machine. But then when you try to do that final build before pushing it to customers, that final build would happen on this EC2 instance, and it would throw some error, and at least you would catch it before it made it to the production servers um and so there's a bunch of tools for this uh you know
你也可以说，只远程构建它。不要在我的机器上做任何事情。然后你可以对进行构建的机器有更多的控制。然后当你去实际构建发布候选版本时，也许你每天或每月做一次，或者其他什么。你可以使用像Jenkins这样的东西，它会在云中启动一台机器，在那台干净的机器上进行构建，然后将其拆除。所以很好地掌握这些工具非常重要。我注意到我们确实跳过了一件事，我们可能只是认为理所当然，那就是在源代码控制中拥有代码，并且每个提交都被检查它是否构建。所以我们正在谈论构建它
this is called a build farm or a test farm um there's a bunch of tools for this i've used build barn in the past i've also used jenkins um there's uh there's github now has github actions um and so these these do uh um a lot of different things you can you can run commands off triggers um but at least in the case of build bar and it also is just transparently hooked up to basil so the way it works is you configure your basil um basil actually has an API for submitting jobs and getting results back. And so you can set up Bazel to point to a build barn instance and say, hey, you can build the code locally on my machine, but you could also build it on this build barn instance.
但所有这一切都始于一个基础，你知道你不是在编译代码，你知道，是一个东西，或者你知道主分支目前是坏的，或者无论你处于什么状态是不可构建的，而且是的，每个人都知道你只需要做这六件事，然后，你知道，然后它构建，之前经历过那个，所以你不能合并到主分支，除非证明该分支之后会很好。是的，是的，是的。这是一个很好的观点。是的，我想，嗯，是的，我的意思是，这是，这是，有很多复杂性。但是是的，我认为在表面层面上，你应该有一组冒烟测试
You could also say, only build it remotely. Don't do anything on my machine. And then you could have a lot more control over the machines that are doing the building. And then when you go to actually build the release candidate, maybe you do that every day or once a month or what have you. You could use something like Jenkins, which would spin up a machine in the cloud, do your build on that clean machine, and then tear it down. And so getting a good handle on these tools is super important. I noticed we did skip over one thing that we probably just took for granted, which is having code in source control and every commit being checked that it builds so we're talking about building it
并说，看，如果这个PR破坏了这些测试之一，或者如果Bazel测试命令不干净，那么我们就不能合并PR，或者你需要像一个特殊的覆盖标志之类的。所以我认为，你知道，这里有一个元观点，那就是，
but all of this starts from a basis that you know you're not compiling code that's you know a thing or that that you know main main branch is currently broken or whatever you know you're on is not buildable and that yeah that everybody knows that you just had to do these six things and then, you know, and then it builds has been on that, then been on that before. So you aren't allowed to merge to main unless that's proven that that branch afterwards will be good. Yep. Yep. Yep. That's a good point. Yeah. I think, uh, um, yeah, I mean, this is, this is, uh, there's a lot of complexity there. But yeah, I think on the surface level, you should have a set of smoke tests
你知道，我们谈论了很多关于设置，你知道，构建农场和测试农场，以及Jenkins等等。但随后有那些元问题，比如，你如何设置它？你知道，
and say, look, if this PR breaks one of these tests, or if the Bazel test command isn't clean, then we can't merge a PR, or you need like a special override flag or whatever. So I think, you know, there's sort of a meta point here, which is,
你如何保证你的Jenkins集群，你知道，与你的生产集群匹配，如果有人，假设将生产集群升级到Ubuntu 22，但构建集群，他们没有将构建集群更新到Ubuntu 22，你如何防止这些错误发生？答案是这个概念，称为基础设施即代码（Infrastructure as Code）。我想缩写也是IAC或IAAC。他们取基础设施中的A。所以你在这里想做的是，你实际上不想，在企业环境或商业环境中，
you know, we've talked a lot about setting up, you know, build farms and testing farms and, and Jenkins and all of that. But then there's those meta question of like, how do you set that up? You know,
你实际上不想进入亚马逊网页界面并点击通过，创建一个新的虚拟机并为其分配一个以太网适配器。作为业余爱好者，或者如果你正在做一个研究项目或一次性的事情，做这些事情很棒。但对于生产，你不想使用亚马逊或谷歌云，任何这些UI并启动东西，因为你可能只是点击了一个别人没有想到的选项，认为那是正确的方法。然后调试它变得非常困难。
how do you guarantee that your jenkins cluster you know matches your production cluster and if somebody let's say upgrades the production cluster to ubuntu 22 but the build cluster they didn't update the build cluster to ubuntu 22 how do you keep those errors from happening um and the answer is this concept called infrastructure as code. I think it's also the acronym is IAC or IAAC. They take the A in infrastructure. And so what you want to do here is you don't actually want, in a corporate setting or a business setting,
你如何保证你的Jenkins集群与生产环境集群相匹配？如果有人将生产集群升级到了Ubuntu 22，但构建集群却没有同步更新，你该如何避免这些错误发生？答案就是“基础设施即代码”这一概念，缩写为IaC。他们取了Infrastructure中的A。因此，在企业或商业环境中，你实际上并不希望这样做，
you don't actually want to go into the Amazon web interface and click through and create a new VM and assign it an Ethernet adapter. Doing these things is great as a hobbyist or if you're doing a research project or a one-off thing. But for production, you don't want to be using the Amazon or Google Cloud, any of these UIs and spinning things up because you might just click an option that someone else didn't thinking that's the right way to go. And then it becomes really hard to debug that.
你实际上并不希望进入亚马逊的网页界面，通过点击来创建新的虚拟机并分配以太网适配器。作为业余爱好者，或者进行研究项目或一次性任务时，这样做很好。但对于生产环境，你不应该使用亚马逊或谷歌云等任何UI来启动资源，因为你可能会点击一个别人没选的选项，误以为那是正确的方法，这会导致后续调试变得非常困难。
Or what if you need to spin up like a ninth machine, but Bob span up the first eight machines and Bob isn't there. And so everyone's waiting for bob right so so um so what the most popular tool for this is or language for this is terraform um terraform is a tool and a language i believe uh there is a you know dot tf files that have their own domain specific language there's There's some actually issue, some drama around this, where I guess there's like an open-source fork and HashiCorp, which runs the closed fork. There's some issues there.
或者如果你需要启动第九台机器，但鲍勃启动了前八台，而鲍勃现在不在，大家都在等他，那该怎么办？目前最流行的工具或语言是 Terraform。Terraform 既是工具也是语言，我相信它有以 .tf 结尾的文件，这些文件有自己特定的领域语言。这其实有一些争议，比如有一个开源分支，而 HashiCorp 运营着闭源分支，这里面确实存在一些问题。
But I think from what I've been reading, Terraform isn't going anywhere, and it's not going to get completely proprietorized or anything like that. So I'd highly recommend Terraform. The way it works is it's really clever. Um, so Terraform looks at your cloud, uh, whenever Terraform, okay, let me take a step back. So Terraform is this script that procedurally like lists, uh, a bunch of things that should exist. Like you should have this VM,
但我读到的信息显示，Terraform 不会消失，也不会完全变成私有软件。所以我强烈推荐 Terraform。它的工作方式非常巧妙。Terraform 会查看你的云环境，等等，让我退一步说。Terraform 是一个脚本，它按程序列出了一堆应该存在的资源，比如你应该有一台虚拟机，
it should have this much memory, it should have this, you know, Ubuntu image on it, and then it should also be able to tunnel through to this other VM, et cetera, et cetera. And so the first time you run this, you have an empty cloud. And so Terraform goes through the list and creates all of those pieces of software
它应该有这么多内存，应该有某个 Ubuntu 镜像，而且它还应该能够通过隧道连接到另一台虚拟机等等。当你第一次运行它时，你的云是空的，所以 Terraform 会遍历列表并创建所有这些软件基础设施。
infrastructure right um but when it creates them it puts special tags and then it creates this this cache file which you put into your source control and that keeps a history so terraform hey, I Terraform, you know, created this VM from this git commit of Terraform code. And so then all you have to do is change that Terraform file and say, oh, actually, it has 32 gigs of RAM. And then the next time you run TF apply Terraform again, because it's tagged everything, it knows what it created versus what you know patrick created and so it looks at all the things it created it looks at the new terraform file and it realizes what it needs to change and so it will actually just add ram to a vm or rename it
但在创建它们时，它会打上特殊的标签，并创建一个缓存文件，你将其放入源代码管理中，这样就保留了历史记录。Terraform 会记录：“嘿，我 Terraform 是根据这个 Git 提交的代码创建了这台虚拟机。”所以之后你只需要修改那个 Terraform 文件，比如改成 32GB 内存。当你再次运行 TF apply 时，因为它给所有东西都打了标签，它知道哪些是它创建的，哪些是帕特里克创建的，所以它会对比它创建的所有资源和新的 Terraform 文件，找出需要更改的地方，然后它只会给虚拟机增加内存或重命名，
or something like that instead of just deleting everything and starting over. You can, as you would expect, you can do weird things that make Terraform very confused. And then it's like, I don't really know how to fix this. But if you're not trying, you'll almost never have a situation like that. In practice, Terraform pretty easily knows how to make that leap um and so this will help guarantee that everything's on the same page so imagine you know you'd have one place in Terraform that says this is my production Linux image and someone just changes that one line to like Ubuntu 22 and under the hood Terraform might like reformat a thousand machines but it's going
或者做类似的操作，而不是删除一切重新开始。当然，你也可以做一些奇怪的操作让 Terraform 感到困惑，导致它不知道该怎么修复。但如果你不是故意捣乱，几乎不会遇到这种情况。实际上，Terraform 很轻松就能完成这种转换。这有助于确保所有人的配置保持一致。想象一下，你在 Terraform 中有一个地方定义了生产环境的 Linux 镜像，如果有人把那一行改成了 Ubuntu 22，Terraform 在底层可能会重新格式化一千台机器，但它会
to do it all in one step and uh and that's going to keep uh inconsistencies popping up i think for you know not only being able to do that but also having as code checked in and a history of of the changes is of course uh you know definitely useful so having something that you can have other people approve before you just apply because i think it's another instance everyone's heard about is someone goes in and just makes a change and nobody knew or wasn't documented and then everything's broken and no one knows why so yep uh another popular thing to do is what's called blue green deployment have you heard this term is that ab deployment i yeah pretty much so blue green just means you have two copies of your
一步到位地完成。这能防止不一致的情况出现。我认为不仅能做到这一点，而且将代码存入仓库并保留变更历史也非常有用。在应用变更前让其他人审批也是必要的，因为大家都听说过这种情况：有人直接进去做了修改，没人知道也没记录，结果一切都坏了，没人知道原因。是的，另一个流行的做法叫“蓝绿部署”。你听过这个术语吗？是 AB 部署吗？是的，差不多。蓝绿部署意味着你有两套基础设施。
infrastructure and so for example like the upgrading ubuntu example so you want to upgrade all the machines at once um and just have one clean atomic operation. The problem is, of course, it takes time to upgrade a thousand machines. And so you don't want your website to be down while you're doing that. And so Blue Green is just a fancy way of saying have two copies. And so you upgrade the first copy. And while you're doing that, all the traffic goes to the second copy. And then you switch the traffic copy. And while you're doing that, all the traffic goes to the second copy and then you
比如刚才提到的升级 Ubuntu 的例子，你想一次性升级所有机器，并进行一次干净的原子操作。问题在于，升级一千台机器需要时间，你不想在升级过程中让网站宕机。所以蓝绿部署就是一种花哨的说法，意思是有两套副本。你先升级第一套，在升级期间，所有流量都流向第二套。然后你切换流量，
switch the traffic over. And so it's kind of like if you've ever done a ropes course, you know how like you're you have two harnesses and so you disconnect one harness from a rope to connect it to another rope. But if while you're connecting it to other rope, you fall, it's OK because you still have the second harness. And one time I went to a place where I don't know how they did this, but some kind of mechanical or magnetic thing where basically if if if. Yeah, I think it was it was a circuit like if you hadn't completed the circuit by locking one of the locks, then the other one couldn't be open so like you you physically couldn't unhitch both of the harnesses at the same time and you know do something dangerous um and so blue green is kind of like that where um you know while you're making a change to blue you can't send any traffic to it and then it flips i only, you know, this being singular stuff,
切换流量。这就像你玩过绳索课程吗？你有两个安全扣，你从一根绳子上解开一个扣去连接另一根绳子。但如果你在连接过程中掉下来也没关系，因为你还有第二个扣。有一次我去了一个地方，我不知道他们是怎么做的，但有一种机械或磁性装置，基本上如果你没有通过锁住其中一个锁来完成回路，另一个就无法打开。所以你物理上不可能同时解开两个安全扣，从而避免危险。蓝绿部署有点像这样，在修改“蓝”环境时，你不会向它发送任何流量，然后进行切换。
but I think part of what we're talking about is leading to making sure that all of these things are repeatable, and that they happen frequently. So I, you know, saying, Oh, we haven't deployed a new one of these or checked on anything in a month or three months or four months or six months, you build up a lot of changes, assuming your code's going under, you know, active deployment or packages that you're using are getting upgraded. And, you know, security vulnerabilities, we've not talked about, but monitoring and updating because of those. And so making sure that you're continuously integrating your code into the system, and then, you know, deploying those things out at some cadence. I mean, it's not in the mathematical sense continuous, but just doing it at a constant repetitive interval prevents there from being
但我认为我们讨论的部分内容是为了确保所有这些操作都是可重复的，并且经常发生。如果你说“哦，我们已经一个月、三个月、四个月甚至半年没部署过新东西或检查过任何东西了”，那么你就会积累大量的变更。假设你的代码在持续部署，或者你使用的软件包在更新，还有我们没提到的安全漏洞，都需要监控和更新。所以要确保代码持续集成到系统中，并按一定的节奏部署。虽然不是数学意义上的连续，但保持恒定的重复间隔可以防止出现
large, gigantic changes. And it somewhat becomes a self-fulfilling problem where you wait a really long time because each time you do it is hard, but then the longer you wait, the worse it becomes. And so then of course it's hard because more stuff has changed and more stuff can break if you're doing that process of build test deploy you know just consistently and constantly and there's nearly not too much to be afraid of and so you may still have a acceptance testing phase in there or whatever so it's not although it has its own merits but it's not the the classical build go fast and break things you're not saying it has to be that way it's just being always in the process of doing these things so they're not a we do this once a year and everyone forgets what to
巨大且复杂的变更。这在某种程度上变成了一个自我实现的预言：因为每次操作都很困难，所以你拖延很久，但拖得越久，情况就越糟。因为变更的东西更多，更容易出错。如果你坚持进行“构建-测试-部署”的流程，就没什么好怕的。你可能仍然会有验收测试阶段，虽然它有其优点，但它不是那种经典的“快速行动并打破常规”。你不需要非得那样，只是要始终处于这些流程中，这样就不会变成“我们一年做一次，中间大家都忘了该怎么做”的情况。
do in the meantime yep yep yep totally right and once you have a lot of this automated and in code, then you can do this continuously. Imagine if you had a software librarian who was cutting a release every five minutes. It's just not practical. I mean, to be clear, there is a role of software librarian. I'm sure in some companies they're still there but i yes i think we used to work at a place that had a software librarian who at a once a week interval actually was responsible for making sure all the code compiled i would not recommend that yeah no i wouldn't recommend that either but to your point they couldn't do it every five minutes so they got kicked out to say once a week it is this person's job to take all the code review all the changes make summary reports and and you know what we now
没错，完全正确。一旦你实现了自动化并将其代码化，你就可以持续进行。想象一下，如果有一个软件管理员每五分钟发布一次版本，那是不切实际的。当然，确实有“软件管理员”这个角色，我相信有些公司还有。是的，我想我们以前工作的地方就有个软件管理员，每周负责确保所有代码都能编译通过。我不推荐这样做。是的，我也不推荐。但重点是，他们无法每五分钟做一次，所以被限制为每周一次，由这个人负责接收所有代码、审查变更、制作汇总报告，而我们现在
just do constantly with computer systems they would do by hand yeah yeah exactly um yeah i remember getting just like software librarian coming over to my desk hey so uh broke the build again it's like um now we have a machine that continuously comes to our desk. Now GitHub puts you on blast. Yeah, that's right. Have you ever done anything interesting, like any interesting real-life triggers? I'll tell a couple from my background.
用计算机系统持续做的事情，他们当时是手工完成的。是的，完全正确。我记得软件管理员走到我桌前说：“嘿，你又把构建搞坏了。”现在我们有一台机器会持续地“走到我们桌前”。现在 GitHub 会直接公开批评你。没错。你做过什么有趣的、现实生活中的触发器吗？我讲几个我背景里的例子。
At one point, we built, we found a way where, okay, you know those... They're like cardboard, but they can be life-size. Like life-size cardboard. Yeah, like statues, I guess is what you'd call them. So there was this one guy who kept breaking the build. And we found a thing, I think it was Zazzle or something, where we could get a life-size cardboard cutout of this engineer.
有一次，我们发现了一种方法，你知道那种……它们像纸板做的，但可以是真人大小。真人大小的纸板。是的，我想你可以称之为雕像。有一个家伙总是把构建搞坏。我们发现了一个网站，好像是 Zazzle 之类的，我们可以定制一个那个工程师的真人大小纸板立牌。
And we had a Raspberry Pi or some Arduino, something set up where his eyes, we put LEDs for eyes. And whenever the build broke, the LEDs flickered. What's the craziest build-breaking thing you've seen? I don't think... I've only ever been on one team, I think, they had some stuffed animal that they would you know take from to whoever was like most recently yeah screwed something up and they would take it to them and that they would you know put it on their desk or
我们装了一个树莓派或 Arduino 之类的东西，把 LED 灯当作他的眼睛。每当构建失败时，LED 灯就会闪烁。你见过最疯狂的构建失败提醒是什么？我想……我只待过一个团队，他们有一个毛绒玩具，谁最近搞砸了，就把玩具拿给谁，让他们放在桌子上，
whatever because they were the most recent person that but no in general i i've always heard stories or you know there's a lava lamp somewhere now still does that there's like lava lamps because they take a while to heat up and start going so if the build is broken the lava lamp somewhere now still does that. There's like lava lamps because they take a while to heat up and start going. So if the build is broken, the lava lamp turns on. And then, you know, you got to try to fix it as fast as you can so that, you know, the whole office doesn't see that the lava lamp is happily bubbling away and the build is broken. This is amazing.
或者其他什么地方，因为他是最近那个搞砸的人。但总的来说，我一直听说有些地方有熔岩灯。因为熔岩灯加热并开始流动需要时间，所以如果构建坏了，熔岩灯就会亮起。然后你得尽快修复它，这样办公室里的人就不会看到熔岩灯在欢快地冒泡，而构建却坏了。这太棒了。
We should have like a New York Times square style ball that drops from the ceiling and if if the build is broken for a whole day it hits the ground and then it uh opens up and there's a pink slip i was thinking there's like a kaleidoscope of uh multi-colored lights but yeah maybe firing is this opens up and there's a little receipt printer and it's a dot matrix printer prints your your yes that oh man um oh man that's so good we uh this is another reason why we need a hybrid workplace that we can haunt each other just working remote just isn't the same um oh man okay so how do we measure uh good and bad devops i think is a really interesting part of this um you know one thing actually maybe i'll start by saying you should measure it um in general my my philosophy here
我们应该在办公室弄一个像纽约时代广场那样的球，从天花板上掉下来。如果构建坏了一整天，它就会落地，然后打开，里面是一张解雇通知书。我刚才在想，是不是应该有一串五颜六色的灯，但也许解雇通知书更好。它打开后，里面有一台小型收据打印机，是一台点阵打印机，打印出你的……是的，那太棒了。这是我们需要混合办公的另一个原因，我们可以互相“骚扰”，远程办公感觉就是不一样。好吧，我们如何衡量 DevOps 的好坏？我认为这是非常有趣的一部分。
maybe this is like a pessimistic view but if you don't measure something you should expect it to be the worst thing possible that's kind of my overall view of it and so or maybe like the worst within some like common sense reasoning and so devops is the same way if you don't measure it then it's not going to be very good. Or another thing that I've seen happen where you don't measure something, and what actually happens is a few people heroically kind of keep it up and running, but then they end up getting burnt out and just feeling like they're not really productive and hurts morale. So measuring things, extremely important.
也许我会先说，你应该去衡量它。总的来说，我的哲学是，也许这是一种悲观的看法，但如果你不衡量某件事，就应该预料到它会变得尽可能糟糕。或者至少在常识范围内是最差的。DevOps 也是一样，如果你不衡量它，它就不会很好。或者我见过另一种情况，如果不衡量，实际上是少数几个人在英雄般地维持系统运行，但他们最终会精疲力竭，觉得没有成就感，从而打击士气。所以衡量指标非常重要。
How to measure DevOps. I'll just start with the simplest one, build times. Build times, test times, deployment time. Is it taking three weeks to build your deployment image? That's a huge problem. Our engineers just sitting there like wrapping their fingers on the desk waiting for the build.
如何衡量 DevOps？我从最简单的开始：构建时间、测试时间、部署时间。构建部署镜像需要三周吗？那是个大问题。工程师们是不是坐在那儿，手指敲着桌子等构建？
That's not good. And so just having a graph of that, I think is a good place to start. We didn't talk too much about that, but I think you're absolutely right. Like builds, if not managed properly by everyone, they become sprawling and take a long time and you know it really kills your ability to iterate so it's very valuable to do what you can to make sure your
那可不好。所以画出这些指标的图表是一个很好的起点。我们没怎么谈这个，但我认为你是对的。如果构建没有被大家妥善管理，它们会变得臃肿且耗时，这真的会扼杀你的迭代能力。所以尽一切努力确保构建快速运行是非常有价值的。
builds run fast yeah i heard a story from the games industry where um they weren't using dlls um there there was this philosophy that like we just want one ex EXE, and the linker was taking 90 minutes. And then at some point, somebody just broke the paradigm and said, look, we're going to put DLLs. And we'll put the DLLs in the same directory as the EXE. Nobody will even notice. And then the linker took like 40 seconds. But people were waiting an hour and a half it's like oh i missed uh well i guess if you miss a semicolon you get a compiler error
是的，我听过游戏行业的一个故事，他们当时没有使用 DLL。当时有一种哲学是“我们只需要一个 EXE 文件”，结果链接器花了 90 分钟。后来有人打破了这个范式，说：“看，我们要用 DLL，把 DLL 放在和 EXE 同一个目录下，没人会注意到的。”结果链接器只花了 40 秒。但人们之前却要等一个半小时。就像是，“哦，我漏了一个分号，得到了一个编译器错误。”
but it's like it's like oh this number was a three it should have been a four 90 minutes you know and that's just that just destroys you know the morale and the productivity um another thing is really important are uh things like release cadence um things like uh bug tracking you know how long uh does it take to fix a bug what's the bug rate you know per week and trying to get that number down um and then the last one which is the most important are surveys um people hate surveys you know i mean outside of work you know i mean you know if someone comes to your door and wants you to know you like are you voting for this you know a school board member or something uh or tell us you know the survey on like this or
但就像是，“哦，这个数字应该是 4 而不是 3”，然后又要等 90 分钟。这真的会摧毁士气和生产力。另一件非常重要的事情是发布节奏，还有 Bug 跟踪，比如修复一个 Bug 需要多久？每周的 Bug 率是多少？并努力降低这个数字。最后一点，也是最重要的，是调查问卷。人们讨厌调查问卷。在工作之外，如果有人敲门问你“你会投票给这个校董会成员吗”或者“告诉我们你是否使用节能灯”，你会想把门甩在他们脸上。
you know do you have energy efficient lights like it feels like one of these things that you just want to slam the door in somebody's face um But at work, especially if it's done right, surveys are extremely important. One example of a case where surveys worked really well, when we built the machine learning backend at Facebook, whenever someone canceled a job, there was a survey. And the way it worked is they could click cancel
但在工作中，如果做得对，调查问卷非常重要。举个例子，我们在 Facebook 构建机器学习后端时，每当有人取消任务，就会有一个调查。它的工作方式是，他们点击取消，
and then just there was a submit button, they could submit. And the survey wasn't in any way forcing people. But there's a little radio button said like, why are you canceling this job? Again, you didn't have to choose, but you could choose user. I think it was called, I don't want this job anymore.
然后有一个提交按钮。调查并没有强迫任何人。但有一个单选按钮写着“你为什么要取消这个任务？”你不需要选择，但你可以选。我想它叫“我不再需要这个任务了”。
Basically, there was a choice. It was like, I made a mistake. Then the rest were all infrastructure. The job isn't finishing, or the system has crashed, or the machines keep going down. Like a whole bunch of choices that were all relevant to things we were trying to do better. And then when you clicked one of those,
基本上，有一个选项是“我犯了个错误”。其余的都是关于基础设施的，比如“任务无法完成”、“系统崩溃”或“机器不断宕机”。这些选项都与我们试图改进的地方相关。当你点击其中一个时，
it popped up a little feedback form, free form. And that was unbelievably useful. So for one, it immediately set a target so people could try to like you know do better on those forms or get get the you know the button press radio button press rates down the second thing is the free form gave us like a whole bunch of really useful context um and what we end up settling on which i think every company should do this is is a a regular survey where we ask people, what is their percent time doing work that they enjoy? And then calling out, what do they not enjoy?
它会弹出一个自由反馈表单，这极其有用。首先，它立即设定了一个目标，人们可以尝试在这些表单上做得更好，或者降低按钮点击率。其次，自由反馈给了我们大量非常有用的背景信息。我们最终确定的是，我认为每家公司都应该这样做：进行定期调查，询问人们花在享受工作上的时间百分比是多少？并指出他们不喜欢什么。
Now, some of these things are, oh, I don't enjoy that we don't have chocolate milk or something. Okay, that's fine. But some of them were like, I don't enjoy just sitting here waiting for my build for an hour. And that is extremely useful information. Have you ever personally, like on any of the teams you've managed, ever done like a survey? You made me think.
现在，有些反馈可能是“我不喜欢我们没有巧克力奶”之类的，那没关系。但有些反馈是“我不喜欢坐在这里等构建等一个小时”。这是非常有用的信息。你有没有在你管理的团队中做过调查？你让我想到了这一点。
I don't think I've ever done that. I've always had like higher level organizational surveys. But have you ever done a survey of just like, you know, send out, hey, everyone, send in information about stuff specific to your team's roles? Yeah, so it's a good point. I'll do it at a low cadence, because you know, the company will do a survey every quarter. Sure. And so sometimes I'll ask for questions to be added to that survey. But But no, I think I'm trying to remember if it's every if it's twice a year or once a year um but yeah we'll do a survey and we'll ask uh you know basically how's it infrastructure you know what are things that are slowing you down what are things that like frustrate you and yeah i think it's it's extremely uh nice to get, get that feedback. I'm going to be cool.
我想我从来没做过。我一直做的是更高级别的组织调查。但你有没有做过那种“嘿，大家，发送关于你们团队角色特定信息”的调查？是的，这是一个好点子。我会以较低的频率做，因为公司每季度会做一次调查。所以有时我会要求在那个调查中增加问题。但我记不清是半年一次还是每年一次了，但我们会做调查，询问基础设施怎么样，什么东西在拖慢你们的速度，什么东西让你们感到沮丧。我认为获得这种反馈非常棒。
Yeah. One interesting thing about surveys is the best results are actually from the people who are the most reluctant to give feedback. Not because they're afraid or anything, but, but you'll have the people who are angry and the people who are ecstatic, you get the feedback from them like that day. Right. But it's the people who are ecstatic, you get the feedback from them like that day. Right.
是的。关于调查的一个有趣之处在于，最好的结果往往来自那些最不情愿提供反馈的人。不是因为他们害怕，而是因为那些愤怒的人和那些狂喜的人，你当天就能从他们那里得到反馈。对吧。
But it's the people who are like on the margin and the people who are like, I'm too busy to do this survey. Those are actually often the people who have the most interesting things to say. And and so it becomes really difficult because you really have to push for, you know, as close to 100% feedback as possible, because as you get closer to 100%, the data gets richer and richer. All right, so I guess we'll end it with any DevOps horror stories. I'll tell one real quick. This wasn't a company I was working at, but we hired somebody. This was, oh gosh, probably like 10 years ago.
但那些处于中间地带的人，以及那些说“我太忙了，没空做调查”的人，往往才是最有话要说的人。这变得非常困难，因为你必须尽可能争取接近 100% 的反馈率，因为越接近 100%，数据就越丰富。好吧，我想我们以 DevOps 的恐怖故事来结束吧。我快速讲一个。这不是我工作的公司，但我们雇了一个人，那是大概 10 年前的事了。
We hired somebody who's telling me a story about their past company, which was a startup. And they had this. So all of their code was Tomcat which was this java uh web service a library and so the way it works is you create a jar file and the jar file i don't think it spins up a web server but i think it it answers web requests and then you hook it up to a web server i'm starting to like get a little hand wavy, a JAR file, for folks who don't know, is literally a zip file. It's a zip file that has certain files
他给我讲了他过去在一家初创公司的故事。他们所有的代码都是 Tomcat，这是一个 Java Web 服务库。它的工作方式是创建一个 JAR 文件，我不认为它会启动 Web 服务器，但它会响应 Web 请求，然后你把它连接到 Web 服务器上。我开始有点含糊其辞了，JAR 文件对于不知道的人来说，字面上就是一个 ZIP 文件。它是一个在特定位置包含特定文件的 ZIP 文件，
in certain places of the zip. And it's just renamed to JAR. That's what it is. So this JAR file knew about how to handle web requests. And it had a bunch of Java bytecode in it. And the way they would do DevOps or deployment is when they made changes to the source code, they would remember what files they changed,
只是重命名为 JAR。这就是它。所以这个 JAR 文件知道如何处理 Web 请求，里面有一堆 Java 字节码。他们进行 DevOps 或部署的方式是，当他们修改源代码时，他们会记住他们修改了哪些文件，
like what.java files. They would take those.class files from their machine, and they would inject them, like replace them in the jar in the zip so they would like ssh into the production machine that's serving all the customer traffic and they would open this in like a zip editor and they would drag their class files from their machine and the website he said would go down like once a week uh because of this no one would know how to fix it oh wow i don't think i other than like having an actual software librarian like we were talking
比如哪些 .java 文件。他们会从机器上取出那些 .class 文件，然后注入到 JAR（ZIP）中。他们会 SSH 到正在处理所有客户流量的生产机器上，用 ZIP 编辑器打开它，然后把他们机器上的 class 文件拖进去。他说网站每周都会宕机一次，因为没人知道怎么修复它。哦，天哪。除了像我们刚才说的有一个真正的软件管理员，
about being ridiculous now i don't know that i have any particular horror stories what about like a downtime ever have you ever been on the crunch where something went down no see we did mostly like internal facing stuff so we've never had like a problem with like slas but you know i i guess we've had issues you know just the kind of normal stuff like somebody built you know with a on a machine that had like a really old version of a library and we didn't even know and then you know like for some reason the code that was everybody was trying to run which does not work we couldn't figure out why no one could reproduce it and there's always this thing when you know when you can't reproduce some problem to just hand wave and say well it's not
这简直太荒谬了。我不知道我还有什么特别的恐怖故事。关于宕机呢？你有没有遇到过那种紧急情况？没有，我们主要做内部的东西，所以从来没有遇到过 SLA 的问题。但我想我们遇到过一些问题，比如有人在机器上构建时，用了一个非常旧的库版本，我们甚至都不知道。然后不知为何，大家都在运行的代码无法工作，我们找不出原因，没人能复现它。当你无法复现问题时，总是会含糊其辞地说“现在没坏”，但每次他们构建时，都会出现同样的问题。最后我们试图找出原因，结果发现“哦，你需要升级这个库”，这个库有一个已知的 Bug。你错过了那封让你更新的邮件。我还有一个故事。这就是 DevOps 走得太远时会发生的事情。我在一个地方工作，他们的 PRCI（即当你想要合并 Pull Request 时运行的测试）
broken now but then every time they would build it it would you know it would have the same issue and so finally we we tried to figure it out and it turned out oh yeah like you need to upgrade this library like this this library had a known bug in it. You missed the email that told you like, please update. I got one last story. This is a, this is what happens when DevOps goes too far in the other direction. I was at this place, which the, the PRCI. So in other words, the tests that run when you have a pull request that you want to get merged
需要花一天时间。有人推送了一个变更，是一个 JavaScript 或 React 的 Bug，导致提交按钮永远不可用，总是灰色的。
in, we're taking like a day and somebody pushed a change where, um, it was a JavaScript or a react, a react bug that they introduced where basically the submit button was never, uh, available. Like it was always grayed out.
所以你可以创建机器学习任务来定义任务，但你无法点击提交按钮来实际启动任务。人们感到很困难。我说：“现在，让我们总是允许人们点击提交按钮。如果人们提交了错误的作业，
So you could like create a machine learning job to define the job and everything, but you couldn't click the submit button to actually launch your job. And so people were having a hard time. And I said, for now, let's just always let people click the submit button. And if people submit a bad job,
它会在后端失败。这能让我们度过今天，因为很多人对此感到不满。”所以我提交了一个单行修改。在 React 代码中，提交按钮的“active”属性是一堆逻辑，我直接删除了 HTML 标签的那部分，这样按钮就总是可以点击了。
it'll just fail on the back end. And that'll just get us through today because a bunch of people are upset about it. So I submitted just a one line change. So literally in the react, it just like in the submit button, the code, it's like active equals a bunch of logic, I just deleted that, that part of that HTML tag, so the button could always be pressed um and then the prci took like half a day and then failed because of like some other change and and basically like you know people were super upset and i couldn't get this like one line html change in uh for like two days um it's just a total disaster.
然后 PRCI 花了半天时间，因为其他变更而失败了。基本上，人们非常不满，我花了整整两天时间才把这一行 HTML 修改提交进去。这简直是一场灾难。
So I think that's a case where, you know, a lot of tests were running and, you know, I'm sure they're catching things in general, but it was also kind of destroying productivity in a different way. Yeah, that's true. We didn't talk about that. Sometimes you may need to just do the crazy thing
所以我认为这是一个例子，大量的测试在运行，虽然它们通常能捕捉到问题，但也以另一种方式摧毁了生产力。是的，那是真的。我们没谈到这一点。有时你可能只需要做点疯狂的事，
and just push a change and just, you know, get rid of all the other stuff because it's in a bad state and the bad state's not letting it get out of the bad state yeah yeah that's right um so yeah i mean you know software librarians probably not a thing anymore but devops is going to be a thing for a long time devops is not going anywhere um if if this kind of stuff is really interesting to you uh you could definitely get a nice uh career for many years doing devops and i think it's a great feel well thank you everyone for for listening through another episode and uh appreciate all of our listeners all the feedback and uh people on. So definitely a shout out to everyone who makes
直接推送一个变更，摆脱所有其他东西，因为它处于糟糕的状态，而这种状态让你无法摆脱困境。是的，没错。所以，软件管理员可能不再存在了，但 DevOps 将长期存在。DevOps 不会消失。如果这类事情让你很感兴趣，你绝对可以在 DevOps 领域拥有多年的美好职业生涯，我认为这是一个很棒的领域。谢谢大家收听这一集，感谢所有听众的反馈。向让世界运转的每一个人致敬。
the world go round. Yeah, totally. Thanks, everybody. We'll catch y'all later. Have a good one. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
是的，完全正确。谢谢大家。我们下次再见。祝大家过得愉快。谢谢。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。